So, schon wieder Stream, Leute.
Jetzt geht's ja schlag... Moment, Vorschau.
Warum sparkt das immer so rum?
Ah, jetzt. Excellent.
Geht ja Schlag auf Schlag hier.
So viele Streams, Alter.
Ja, und zwar, ich hab gesehen, es gibt seit Mai oder so,
oder irgendwie seit ein paar Monaten,
gibt es eine neue Proxmox-Version.
Ich bin ja bisher nicht so großartig damit warm geworden,
was aber nicht heißt, dass es nicht für andere eine gute Sache ist,
also eine gute Lösung ist für das, was wir machen wollen.
Und der hauptsächliche Grund, warum ich es jetzt ausprobiere,
ich hab mir mal hier die neuen Ideen...
Nee, Ideas, nicht Idee.
Aber fast, so aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen.
Was ich ganz interessant... Moment, warum ist das auf Deutsch?
Kann man das auf Englisch stellen?
Excellent. Ach so, stimmt, die kommen ja aus Österreich, die Stream.
Und zwar, ich hab gelesen, dass man jetzt DNS...
Also, erstens hab ich gelesen, dass die jetzt Let's Encrypt machen können.
Weil, oh nee, Splatoon-Musik, hör mal auf.
Splatoon ist so ein Spiel, das verwirrt mich hochgradig.
Also, nicht das Spiel an sich, sondern das Internet.
Und, äh...
Ihr könnt euch wahrscheinlich denken, was ich meine.
Das Internet ist bei sowas immer auf Zack.
Oh, bisschen laut hier.
So, und zwar...
Also, warum ich es jetzt nochmal ausprobiere,
hauptsächlich ist das hier, weil ich gelesen hab,
die machen jetzt Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat
und die können auch DNS-Zertifikate machen.
Das ist ja das, was ich hauptsächlich verwende.
Ah, jetzt ist der Stream am Start.
Wen haben wir denn hier?
Den Toaster ist noch dabei.
Der Skill-Killer Captain Peng, der ist auch öfters am Start.
Sind alle öfters am Start.
Ich kenne ja mittlerweile die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Easy-Killer ist auch am Start.
Pengi, das ist...
Jetzt sind wir ja hier alle am Start, die man so kennt.
Aber in letzter Zeit, ich hab mal geguckt,
kommen immer mehr...
Leute random vorbei.
Also, vermute ich zumindest mal.
Weil, wenn ich so die...
die Follower-Zahlen anschaue,
guck, die gehen immer richtig schön rauf pro Stream.
Jetzt, ich mein, das ist jetzt nicht so wie auf YouTube,
wo sich das irgendwie 30.000, 40.000 Leute angucken.
Aber, ich mein, es ist auch kein YouTube-Content, ja.
So, und ich mein...
Alter, was geht mit der Musik ab?
Das ist ja abartig.
What the fuck?
Das ist schon besser.
Ähm, so.
Ich mein, das ist natürlich jetzt keine Geschichte hier von wegen...
Ähm, YouTube.
Irgendwie mit...
Wo man...
Wo man unter 500 Abos am Tag nicht zufrieden ist oder so.
Ähm, gut, bei mir ist ja eh egal.
Aber...
Aber das stimmt schon gar nicht, weil es ist mittlerweile mehr.
Es kommen jeden Stream neue Sachen, neue Leute dazu.
Das find ich extrem nice.
Und das ohne, dass ich irgendwo Werbung mach.
So muss das sein.
Ich mach hier meine ganzen Kram zu.
Speichern wir mal.
Brauchen wir vielleicht noch...
So.
Ähm, genau.
Wie gesagt, ich hab gelesen, die machen jetzt letztens ein Crypt-Zertifikate.
Und die machen DNS-Challenge.
Das können wir vielleicht...
Vielleicht probieren wir das mal aus.
Mal gucken.
Ähm, da müsste ich nämlich irgendwo meine...
Cloudflare-Zugangsdaten raussuchen.
Und da hab ich Schiss, dass ich die im Zweifelsfall leake.
Deswegen probier...
Deswegen belass ich's vielleicht mal eher bei dem, dass sie's jetzt können.
War das Beep im Stream?
Also bei mir hat nix gepiepst.
Hat's bei euch gepiepst?
Das ist tatsächlich wahr.
Die Streams, wo ich einfach nur Videos gucke und auf irgendwas reacte, werden am meisten geguckt.
Was eigentlich so der Ultra-Low-Effort kommt.
Drei Wochen lang.
Mit diesen Videos.
Und den zweiten, der nicht...
Konfiguriert wurde.
Und wo mal wieder hochgegangen ist.
Und der erste Mal...
Der erste Mal, dass ich mit dem Video auch in den Streams...
Gehört wird.
Und wenn ich mir das jetzt wieder die Stimme jetzt das adjective auf der Facebook accomplishments
verwendet habe, um hier die...
Dann könnt ihr halt einfach mal einen Blick machen.
Die...
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Macht's gut.
Achtung, die Blätter.
Das war's schon so schon...
Wir sind da.
In der...
In der der hier...
Wo?
Was?
Wie?
Also...
Ähm...
keine ahnung man jetzt besser wie hat man das jetzt gar nicht gesehen was ich gemacht habe
gerade moment da stehen guck mal ich habe jetzt das kann jetzt das licht an machen weiß ich ob
das besser aussieht wird das besser aus als ohne licht ich finde das sieht total so krankenhaus
mäßig aus jemand als besser was man sieht die kiste die daneben steht ja vielleicht ich weiß
nicht vielleicht testen noch mal wie high quality die kamera ist und funktioniert hand
league
omfg anliegen gut also wenn das besser aussieht mit beleuchtung mal gucken wie lange das mal
gucken wie lange das iphone durchhält ob man da stundenlang die kamera bzw nicht die kamera
ob man da stundenlang die beleuchtung an lassen kann keine ahnung weiß nicht übrigens was man
hier wieder schön erkennt ist oder oder für die leute die nicht die nicht dabei findet
ihr es nicht merkwürdig dass dann pc express stecker mitten auf dem mainboard
ist ich meine dass da unten pci express stecker ist kennt man ja warum ist da pçe express stecker
das ist wirklich big brain adapter dass es m2 auf pci express das wusste ich bis
als ich dafür gekauft habe gar nicht dass es das überhaupt gibt ja so und zwar das ist die
gleiche kiste ist ich wollte weder zahnologineschnecks will ich wirklich dauerhaft werden ich habe ihr neben
meine vers refinierung bis zum halbjahres projekt entшь bei laxmi spielt und ich habe hier neben
meine kiste stehen wo alles drauf ist wie es ab was ich auch noch küsschen wollte für die chinese
nah influence auf sox natürlich trotzdem ist beg唱 deponhen da wir da ne за ein 나us ein ragazac
Wobei ich wirklich ernsthaft am überlegen bin, ob ich mir da nicht Synology drauf haue.
Ich wollte zwar eigentlich keine VMs laufen lassen, weil es das immer von der Verwaltung ein bisschen komplizierter macht.
Aber ich bin ernsthaft am überlegen, ob ich da nicht noch jetzt eine KVM-Synology-Kiste drauf mache.
Ne, das ist jetzt einfach nur zum Ausprobieren.
Und außerdem interessiert es mich, was die so Neues machen.
Verwenden will ich das eher nicht.
Wie gesagt, für so einen ESX-Style-Unterbau habe ich da eigentlich...
Ja, weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt.
Also für mich ist es am einfachsten, wenn da ein stinknormaler Ubuntu-Server drauf ist.
Ich klatsche ein paar Dinger drauf, die ich brauche und gut ist.
Wofür steht denn das VE?
Äh, Founders Edition.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, für was das steht.
Version? Ne, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Für Virtual Environment?
Keine Ahnung, für was steht...
Proxmox, Wikipedia. Gucken wir mal.
Proxmox Virtual Environment, kurz PVE.
Kannst du letztendlich Kryptan unter Proxmox testen?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das kann.
Weil...
Dann müsste ich meinen Cloudflare-API-Key leaken.
Also dann leake ich vielleicht meinen Cloudflare-API-Key.
Und das suckt.
Ne, DDoSen ist das kleinste Problem, was ich habe,
wenn ich meinen Cloudflare-API...
...API-Key leake, weil er darf alles machen.
Ich könnte mir einen Cloudflare-Account erstellen für...
Ich könnte mir einen Cloud...
Hm.
Wir können uns doch einfach irgendeine...
Oder wenn da Sbarro da ist.
Wenn da Sbarro da ist,
dann können wir das über die Domainform Sbarro machen.
Wenn man da irgendeinen DNS-only-API-Key erstellen kann.
Oder wir machen es über PepoFat.
Ne, PepoFPat.
PepoF.at.
Beste Domain.
War das PepoF.at?
Ne.
Ah, ich habe es vergessen, wie die Domain war.
Der Sbarro ist mit dem Physik-Grill beschäftigt.
Das wäre ja gut für ihn.
Genau, so.
Lass mal gucken, was die Neues haben.
Ah, es gibt einen aktuellen Kernel.
Es gibt neues ZEV-Gedöns.
Wobei, ZEV brauche ich ja nicht.
Ich soll erstmal hier Chat aufmachen,
dass ich wieder ein paar Sachen hochscrollen kann.
Ach so, und was wir auch ausprobieren nachher.
Alter, warum merkt er sich...
...nie, dass ich Dark-Mode haben will?
Ja, was wir auch ausprobieren, ist eine Runde PCI-Passthrough.
Und zwar, ich habe hier noch sowas.
Ich halte es mal kurz in die Kamera.
Das ist eine 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte von Ebay.
Mal gucken, ob die dann erkennen, ob das funktioniert.
Schauen wir mal.
Doch, es gibt beim Linux-Kernler öfters mal LTS-Versionen.
Allerdings verwende ich schon ewig keine LTS-Versionen,
weil ich Manjaro verwende und bin eigentlich ganz froh damit.
So, wie es ist.
So, also.
Herr Kelmau schreibt, überlege mir...
Mal gucken, ob es mein Chatlogger mitgekriegt hat.
Ne, das da.
Schreibt hier, überlege mir meine Windows Gaming 4 mit Pass...
Ne, würde ich nicht machen.
Das macht mehr Probleme.
Überlege mir meine Windows...
Also, ich lese es mal vor.
Überlege mir meine...
Und, so.
Überlege mir meine Windows Gaming 4M mit Pass-to-GPU statt KVM
nun zu Proxmox zu verschieben, schreibt er.
Und mein Haupt-Desktop-Linux auch in eine VM zu verschieben,
da es mir mittlerweile so viele Probleme macht,
die einen Reboot des Host-Systems erfordern.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Würde ich nicht machen.
Du hast...
Das klingt auf den ersten Blick verlockend,
aber ich bin mir sicher, wenn du es verwendest,
kriegst du ordentliche Probleme.
Das Erste, was mir so spontan einfällt, ist,
dass immer mehr Games checken, ob man in der VM läuft.
Beispielsweise dieses eine Ding, was ja gerade...
Was auch der Friseur spielt.
Hier, dieses komische Ayaya-Game.
Das ist zwar ein Singleplayer-Game,
aber die haben ein Anti-Cheat, die gucken, ob man in einer VM läuft.
Und wenn man in einer VM läuft, dann ist nicht Ayaya,
dann ist...
Geht nicht.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Gerade, was Gaming und Windows angeht,
ist so ein Ding, wo ich den größten Vorteil nutzen will.
Und zwar, dass man die Sache einfach anschalten kann
und es geht meistens.
So, und...
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich nicht großartig rumexperimentiere,
auch wenn wir das mal in einem der nächsten Streams ausprobieren.
Also, das ist übrigens auch eine Sache, die müssen wir unbedingt machen.
Wenn ich es denn dann wirklich hinkriege, mal...
Ich mag keine Splatoon-Musik.
So, wenn ich es dann doch mal hinbekommen sollte,
mir einen neuen Rechner zu kaufen,
das liegt aber eher an der Verfügbarkeit von Grafikkarten und neuen CPUs,
wenn ich es dann hinkriege, einen neuen Rechner,
dann testen wir auf dem alten Gaming-Rechner
mal Linux mit Proton und Wine und Gaming-Zeug.
So, ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich dann übelst flamen werde wahrscheinlich
und dann alle sagen, Max, warum regst du dich so auf?
Dann musst du halt mal drei Stunden basteln,
dass du ein Spiel zum Laufen kriegst.
Ist doch nicht schlimm, dafür brauchst du kein Windows.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
In der Richtung.
Ich find's geil, dass ich teilweise als Linux-Fanboys
mich dann hier im Stream manchmal mit Linux-Fanboys schlagen muss,
wenn ich irgendwas Negatives sag, was ich nicht gut finde.
Komm, nein, nein, nein, das liegt da nicht dran.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Zumindest eine Sache finde ich gut,
was hier anders ist als auf YouTube.
Wenn ich auf YouTube irgendwelche Videos gemacht hab,
wo es um Technik-Sachen geht,
zum Beispiel, ich hatte ja mal was gemacht über...
Warte mal, wie hieß das?
Meltdown?
Da hab ich ja sogar...
Also, ich mein, das war...
Man darf das mal...
Moment.
Sag mal, hat die PC-Welt mein Thumbnail?
Das sieht ja fast genauso aus wie mein Thumbnail, Alter.
Zumindest, ich hab auf YouTube mal ein Video gemacht
über Shellshock und Heartbleed und Meltdown und solche Geschichten.
Und ich hab das am gleichen Tag gemacht.
Ist die Musik eigentlich zu laut, zu leise?
Passt so?
Ich hab das am gleichen Tag gemacht.
Und ich muss euch sagen, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
das ist ungefähr zweieinhalb Jahre her.
Ähm.
Und ich hab das am gleichen Tag gemacht.
Und ich hab mir sogar extra das Original-Paper durchgelesen.
Was die...
War das nicht an irgendeiner Schweizer Uni?
War das nicht an irgendeiner...
An irgendeiner...
Ich zeig das Paper doch hier drin.
Oh ja, meine Array-Malkünste, lecker, ja.
Ähm.
Zeigt, dass ich...
Zumindest, ich hab mir sogar das Original...
Die Original-Veröffentlichung davon angeguckt.
Ja.
War das die ETH Zürich?
Einstein wäre Scholz, ja.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das war aber, glaube ich, nicht die ETH Zürich.
Ähm.
Meltdown, Bug, Discovery.
Welche, welche waren das nochmal?
Ähm.
Hamburg?
Hier.
Graz.
Wie spricht man daraus?
Graz?
Das heißt bestimmt nicht Graz, weil wir sind ja nicht in MMOs.
Genau.
Äh.
Da haben sie das entdeckt.
GZ.
GG.
GL.
Ähm.
Und ich hab am gleichen Tag dieses Video gemacht über Meltdown.
Das heißt, ich hab mir das Paper soweit durchgelesen und das ist wirklich nicht ohne.
Ja.
Also.
Da zum größten Teil ist das okay, aber die Details waren nicht ohne.
Vor allem das hier.
Wo ich sie hier...
Gerade im Video hab, wo es darum ging, was sie hier für Assembler-Dinger machen, dass man das ausnutzen kann.
Also nur mal so zur Erklärung, ganz, ganz kurz rückwirkend.
Ähm.
Der Trick bei Meltdown...
Alter, was hat der denn mit seiner Splatoon-Musik?
Das geht mir voll auf den Keks.
Ich mag keine Splatoon-Musik.
Das Mario Kart.
Also, bei Meltdown ging es nicht darum, dass man auf Sachen zugreifen kann, auf die man nicht zugreifen können sollte, so ohne weiteres.
Nein.
Beim Meltdown hat man die Zugriffszeiten gemessen und konnte dadurch erkennen, was schon mal gecached war und was nicht.
So.
Ganz, ganz grob.
Und dadurch konnte man quasi anhand des Indexes, welcher gecached war, erkennen, welcher Wert ausgelesen wurde aus dem Bereich, den man eigentlich ausgelesen können sollte.
So, also Meltdown war wirklich ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge, so.
Und ich hab am gleichen Tag ein Video gemacht und ich muss sagen, also ich finde, dass das zumindest im deutschsprachigen Raum das beste Video zum Thema für Leute war, die...
...das nicht täglich machen.
Äh, das Background und Meltdown waren sich recht ähnlich.
Aber das war Meltdown, was ich da in dem Video erklärt habe.
So, zumindest, warum ich das jetzt alles erzähle ist, ich muss jetzt zwar öfters mit irgendwelchen Linux-Fanboys diskutieren auf dem Stream.
Ich meine, ich bin ja selber einer, aber deswegen finde ich das besonders lustig.
Aber eine Sache ist hier, ist hier nicht, äh, ist hier im Stream nicht so.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich auf YouTube so ein Video mache und das, warum ich jetzt so lange aushole ist, das Video war echt nicht ohne.
Und das war schon ein bisschen Research dabei und das war auch nicht einfach und alles.
Aber du hast hier, wenn du die Kommentare durchscrollst, wieder so, Max, Max, sehr viel gefährliches Halbwissen verbreitet.
Hättest du mal genauer schauen sollen und solche, solche Wichtigtuer.
Die haben wir hier im Stream nicht.
Hier im Stream haben wir manchmal Leute, die gehen mir zwar auch auf den Keks, aber nicht so dieses typische YouTube-Dumm-Gelaber, was es immer gegeben hat.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Ja, das ist ja okay, da hat er ja auch recht, da war ich ein bisschen schnell.
So, aber, ist das, äh, Twilight Princess?
Ja, naja, und das haben wir, das haben wir hier im Stream glücklicherweise nicht.
Das ist, das ist auch das, was mir an YouTube am meisten auf den Keks geht.
Das ist so eine Sache, die mich an YouTube am meisten motiviert und am meisten auf den Keks geht.
Und zwar, einmal lese ich gerne Comments von Leuten und da gibt's natürlich auf YouTube immer jede Menge Comments, ne, und Zeug, das interessiert mich ja.
Aber, auf der anderen Seite geht mir YouTube auf den Sack, weil so viele dumme Leute am, am Start sind.
Übrigens, heute Morgen war ich im Rewe, hab mir was vom Bäcker geholt, hab mich draußen kurz davor gesessen und was, und was gefuttert.
Und da ist die Bäckerfrau dann rausgekommen und da hat sich mit einer anderen Bäckerfrau drüber unterhalten, ob's Corona gibt oder nicht.
Weißt du, wenn man das immer so hört, dann denkt man sich, ja, okay, es wird schon so Leute geben, aber eigentlich, eigentlich kann ich's mir nicht vorstellen.
Und dann hast du sie live am Start, ja.
Die war Querdenker.
Ey, ich hab mir überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit, wenn, wenn Leute die Maßnahmen irgendwie hinterfragen, weil das ist wirklich fragwürdig, was da gemacht wird.
Äh, oder, oder den Zusammenhang zwischen Maßnahmen und Auswirkungen, so ist ja alles okay.
Aber dass man prinzipiell bezweifelt, dass es das Virus gibt oder dass es Viren gibt, ist schon ein bisschen sehr weit hergeholt.
Ja.
Dafür, wenn man sich die Sachen mal genauer anguckt.
Aber das ist, das ist ungefähr genauso, wie wenn man, wie wenn man bezweifelt, dass, keine Ahnung, der, der Mond um die Erde kreist oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist so, so Dinger, das kommt ja gerade wieder auf, so in letzter Zeit, aber das, das sind so Sachen, die kann ich irgendwie nicht ernst nehmen.
Ach, stimmt, ja, und Bill Gates, der die Leute chippen will und so, ja, was auch immer.
Aber meine Lieblings, meine Lieblingssache, wenn's um so richtig abgedrehte Logos...
...lustige Verschwörungstheorien gibt, ist, dass Obamas Bodyguard Reptilienmensch ist.
Also das ist meine persönliche Lieblingstheorie in der Richtung.
Warum hat der Typ so viel Splatoon-Musik?
Ja, den Kerl gibt's auch noch.
So.
Also, jetzt kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache.
Ich muss mal kurz durch den Chat gehen.
Da gab's nämlich ein paar offene Sachen.
Subs hab ich hoffentlich keine übersehen.
Was hältst du davon?
Moment, kann ich dir gleich sagen.
Ach, das ist die Geschichte.
Das halt ich persönlich für Schwachsinn.
Da hatten wir's...
Was zum...
Was ist mit der Seite los?
Ich mein, die sah eben schon in weiß nicht gut aus, aber in grün sieht sie ja noch schlimmer aus.
Ähm, das hatten wir vor ein paar Tagen schon mal.
Ich halte das für schwachsinnig.
Das liegt zum größten Teil da...
Also, die hauptsächliche Sache, dass ich noch mal kurz sagen kann, warum ich glaube, dass das Schwachsinn ist, ist folgendes.
Microsoft müsste so viele Custom-Patches pflegen für irgendwie den Linux-Kernel, dass der Kram nicht mehr da ist.
Also, ich glaube, dass der Kram nicht mehr da ist.
Weil der Kram so funktioniert, wie es funktioniert.
Weil da gerade der Vorteil ist, dass Windows auch sehr viele...
äh...
Binary...
...proprietäre Binary-Plob-Treiber mit allen möglichen Genüsse hat,
ähm...
die so definitiv niemals in den Linux-Kernel kommen werden.
Da müsste Microsoft quasi einen so ehem...
... ein bisschen ähnlich wie Android,
bloß noch viel viel mehr.
Die bräuchten einen Custom-gepatchten Linux-Kernel, der quasi den halben Kernel umschreibt.
Und dann ist halt die große Preisfrage, richtig?
Warum sollten die das machen, wenn sie einfach Windows weiterverwenden können?
Das ergibt für mich, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Und...
Eines der Argumente, die hier teilweise angeführt werden, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das hier aufgegriffen haben, aber hier in dem Ursprungssache ist es drin, dass Microsoft in Azure ja mittlerweile auch schon mehr, die Musik ist mir irgendwie ein bisschen laut, genau, also eines der Argumente war ja, die angeführt wurden, dass Microsoft ja in Azure mittlerweile mehr Linux betreibt als Windows.
Ja, ist ja kein Wunder, das glaube ich sofort. Linux ist für so Serversachen in Azure auch einfach besser geeignet als Windows und mit Linux kostet nichts, weil ich glaube nicht, dass in Azure eine Windows-Lizenz dabei ist.
Zumindest bei den Azure-Kisten, die ich bisher verwendet habe, war keine Windows-Lizenz dabei.
Ich habe hier sogar noch den Screenshot aus der Azure-Schulung, wo Windows gefragt hat, ob man nicht aktivieren möchte.
1337, nein, das wusste ich nicht. Das wusste ich nicht.
Er schreibt, Max, hast du gewusst, dass Justin Bieber...
...Biebers Affe, über den du 2013 mal ein Video gemacht hast, vor zwei Jahren Mutter geworden ist?
Exzellent, das ist wichtig zu wissen.
So, ich glaube, ich habe den Chat durch.
Ja, ich bin im Chat unten angekommen. Exzellent.
Fangen wir mit Proxmox gleich an. Ja.
Hast du Erfahrung mit GPU-Treiber auf Linux installieren?
Ne, das ist glaube ich fünf Jahre her, wo ich das letzte Mal gemacht habe.
Ansonsten habe ich nur Notebooks verwendet mit integriertem Intel-Treiber, da musst du nichts installieren.
Oder hier.
Desktop in meiner VM.
So, falls ich irgendwas im Chat übersehen habe, ich fange jetzt an, ähm, schreibt es einfach nochmal.
So, erstmal einen Dark-Reader anmachen, dass ich jetzt hier nicht irgendwie erblinde.
Aber angeblich sind mittlerweile AMD-Treiber auch gar nicht so übel unter Linux.
Früher war es ja Nvidia-only, also Intel immer schon, aber dann mehr oder weniger fast nur Nvidia.
Und mittlerweile wohl auch halbwegs AMD.
Xerox Xenio, 13 Monate, exquisite Subscription, huge.
Exzellent.
So.
Hast du schon mal Risk-Fakt... Das ist die China-CPU, nein, die habe ich noch nicht angeguckt.
Äh, was läuft denn aktuell bei dir, wenn nicht Proxmox?
Ähm, fragt Business-Raster.
Bei mir läuft mittlerweile, ich habe ja, ich habe ja richtig, richtig hart downgradet.
Es ist gut, dass ich ein Video darüber gemacht habe, weil da kann ich das immer zeigen, wenn es darum geht.
Ich hatte ja früher hier ein bisschen Overkill installiert.
So, mit, äh...
Alter YouTube.
Das geht mir in letzter Zeit wirklich auf den Keks.
Ja, mit dieser fetten Kiste hier oben und dem ganzen anderen Zeug.
Ich habe jetzt downgradet auf eine 2HE-Kiste, ähm, mit Low-Power-Internet-Plattformen.
Und da läuft einfach ein stinknormales Ubuntu-1804-Server drauf, mit ein paar Docker-Containern fertig.
Und eine 12TB-Platte für File-Server.
Und eine externe Platte, wo einmal nachts drauf gesynct wird.
Also ich habe, ich habe hart zurückgefahren.
Was man aber auch...
Was man auch im Stromverbrauch sieht.
Es ist nicht so, dass das Rack ultra viel verbraucht hat.
Aber es ist halt schon ein Unterschied, ob du 100 Watt Eidel brauchst oder nur noch 30.
Oder eher 150 und jetzt 30.
Wohl gemerkt für das ganze Rack, ja.
Was genau ist Proxmox?
Sowas wie ESX, falls du das kennst.
Pasi.
Weiß nicht, ob dir das was sagt.
Das ist quasi eine Plattform für Container und VMs.
Interface.
So ein bisschen was wie ESX.
So.
Also, guck mal mal.
Download.
Okay, wir müssen, Achtung Leute, Sonnenbrille aufziehen.
Ups.
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
What the f...
Äh, das da?
ISO-Images.
Download.
Jawohl.
Mit VLC, alles klar.
Jetzt immer mit VLC öffnen.
Was haben die sonst noch?
Proxmox Backup-Server.
Was ist denn das?
Ach gut, Braumer Ehnert.
Borg-Backup-Beste.
Falls jemand, weil ich öfters mal gefragt werde, mit was ich Backups mache.
Beste.
Beste Backup-Tool.
Hat nicht umsonst 6600 Sterne auf GitHub.
Geht unter Windows auch.
Wird, glaube ich, offiziell nicht supporten unter Windows.
Ist aber kein Problem, unter Windows laufen zu lassen.
Es ist ein bisschen, also es braucht ein bisschen Eingewöhnung, bis man sich da...
...reingearbeitet hat.
Aber dann ist es das beste Backup-Tool.
Du hast Verschlüsselung, De-Duplication, Kompression, alles in einem.
Du kannst das ganze Snapshot, äh, nicht Snapshot, nicht Snapshot, ähm, rotieren.
Inkrementell machen, dann wieder, ähm, Moment, wie heißt es?
Inkrementell und Full Backup.
Also das ist wirklich gut.
Kann ich jedem empfehlen, sich das nochmal anzugucken.
Und ich glaube, es gibt mittlerweile auch ein halbwegs brauchbares Web-UI.
Hi, kommt eigentlich ein Video auf deinem Kanal?
Ja.
Tatsächlich, ähm, ob ihr mir es glaubt oder nicht, ich hab gestern Mittag versucht, was aufzunehmen.
Allerdings zu einem, keinem Gaming-Thema.
Und zwar, ähm, wie ihr alle wisst, Moment, äh, wie ihr alle wisst, ist, ähm, bin ich ja mittlerweile 36.
Auch wenn, das überrascht immer viele Leute irgendwie.
Also ja, ich bin 36.
Ich bin jetzt hier vom Rechner und, äh, erzähl was von Poggers und blende komische Emotes ein.
Aber, ha, ha, ha, ich bin 36.
Ich bin 1984 geboren.
Also ich bin so zwischen Zoomer und Boomer-Generation.
Ich bin, also, wenn man es genau nimmt, eigentlich, ich, ich mein, ich war ja relativ jung noch im Jahr 2000.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt Doomer bin.
Keine Ahnung, zumindest, zumindest bin ich ja mittlerweile 36.
Und ich wollte ein Video machen.
Ich wollte ein Video mal dazu machen.
So zu einer Sache, die ich gelernt hab mittlerweile mit 36.
Und, wo ich finde, wo relativ wenig dazu gesagt wird.
Ich will, ich will jetzt nicht großartig rumschwätzen.
Ich sag nur mal kurz, um was es geht.
Ich hab's im, ich hab's im Stream ja auch schon, ich hab's ja im Stream auch schon öfters gesagt.
Ähm, es gibt so oft die, es, es, es gibt überall so Motivationssprüche, ja.
Auf Twitter hauen manche Leute irgendwelche, äh, Motivationstweets raus.
So hier in Richtung, just do it und sonst was.
Oder in Videos.
Und eines der Ratschläge.
Die man bei diesen ganzen Motivationsdingern total oft hört, ist, man soll drauf scheißen, was andere Leute sagen.
Und da hab ich ein bisschen andere Meinung zu.
Und dazu hab ich ein Video aufgenommen.
Weil ich bin der Meinung, dass drauf scheißen, was andere Leute sagen, erstens nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist.
Manchmal ist es ganz sinnvoll, was andere Leute sagen.
Aber es geht ja hauptsächlich bei diesen Aussagen drum, was andere Leute über dich sagen.
Oder wenn andere Leute über dich irgendwie sagen, du bist kacke.
Ja, dass man das, dass man das nicht so, dass einem das egaler sein sollte.
So, das ist ja der Grund.
Die Aussage, die da öfters getroffen wird.
Und ich finde, das trifft's nicht so ganz.
Das ist, damit anzufangen ist bescheuert, wenn man nicht den ersten Schritt gemacht hat.
Und der erste Schritt ist meiner Meinung nach, bevor man drauf scheißen kann, was andere Leute von einem halten, ähm,
muss man erstmal mit sich selbst halbwegs zufrieden sein.
Sonst klappt das nicht.
Das sagt sich so einfach, so nach dem Motto, scheiß drauf, was andere sagen.
Aber solange du eben nicht selbst so halbwegs mit dir zufrieden bist,
kannst du, wirst du es nie im Kopf auf die Reihe kriegen, drauf zu scheißen, was andere sagen.
Das heißt, der erste Schritt ist eigentlich erstmal, dass man selbst mal so in sich geht
und sich überlegt, ist man eigentlich mit sich selbst zufrieden.
Und wenn man dann mit sich selbst zufrieden ist, irgendwann mal, ähm, dann ist der zweite Schritt eigentlich total einfach.
Und man braucht den zweiten Schritt gar nicht bewusst zu machen, weil der zweite Schritt kommt von ganz allein.
Wenn man, wenn man, ich meine, das heißt jetzt nicht, dass man komplett drauf scheißen soll, wenn jetzt einer sagt, hier, guck mal, Max,
äh, was weiß ich, die Präsentation, die du gehalten hast, war an den und den Punkten schlecht.
Das ist okay, da kann man dem ja zuhören.
Das, das ist ja damit nicht gemeint.
Ähm, aber wenn man zumindest halbwegs damit zufrieden ist, ja, und sich nicht bei, bei jedem Furz, den ein anderer sagt, gleich in Frage stellt, so, was man so macht,
dann ist einem das eigentlich auch egal, da braucht man den zweiten Schritt gar nicht mehr.
Und das ist, das ist eigentlich meiner Ansicht nach so der, der Schritt, den man, den früher oder später jeder mal machen muss,
wenn er nicht im Kopf durchdrehen muss.
Also, wenn, wenn du nicht irgendwie total, ähm, ja, wenn du nicht mit der Zeit total irgendwelche psychischen Probleme entwickeln willst,
ja, Selbstbewusstsein, weiß ich, ob es das trifft, ja, aber sowas in der Richtung.
Was, wovon ich auch nichts halte, ähm, ist so diese übertriebenen, diese übertriebenen Selbstbewusstseinskurse, die es da teilweise gibt,
wo man sich, wo sich halt Leute, die übelste Spasten sind, einreden, dass sie die Größten sind.
Das ist halt auch nicht Sinn und Zweck.
Es ist schon nicht verkehrt, wenn man selbst in der Lage ist, zu erkennen, wenn man Scheiße macht.
Also, das ist auch nicht verkehrt, ja, das ist ja damit auch nicht gemeint.
Zum, aber, aber, man sollte irgendwann mal wirklich sich Gedanken über sich selbst machen und so überlegen,
okay, was sind denn Sachen, das heißt ja auch nicht, dass man nicht irgendwas ändern kann an dem, was man macht, ne, das spricht ja,
aber man muss die Sachen nicht unbedingt nur ändern, weil jetzt, jetzt das andere Leute von einem wollen,
sondern es ist halt die Frage, wenn man sagt, hey, mal angenommen, ne,
also, sagen wir mal, ihr wisst ja, ich hab's ja schon öfters gesagt, ich mag tiefes Wasser nicht.
Es gibt so zwei Sachen, vor denen ich Schiss habe.
Das sind einmal Spinnen und tiefes Wasser.
Ja, ich weiß, das können viele Leute nicht verstehen, aber ich, ich hab Schiss vor tiefem Wasser.
Vor allem tief, ich glaube aber, das ist gar nicht so wenig verbreitet.
So, also du kannst mich weder mit Schlangen, mit Mäusen, mit sonst was irgendwie, mit Blutkotze, sonst was, juckt mich alles nicht,
ähm, Spinnen und tiefes Wasser.
So, und wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ey, ich möchte, ich kann schwimmen, klar, ich kann sogar relativ,
okay, ich gebe zu, ich gehe nicht mehr oft schwimmen, aber ich hatte alle durch, bis Gold, bis Goldabzeichen auf der Hose, wie ich klein war, ja.
Ähm, das ist nicht das Problem. Ich kann im Schwimmbad ohne Probleme schwimmen.
Was ich überhaupt nicht mag, ist Baggersee.
Also Baggersee, das kriege ich nicht hin.
Da sieht man nämlich nichts.
Im Meer, im Meer ist kein Problem, ja, aber, ähm,
wie tief ist tief?
Eigentlich reicht mir schon, wenn es tief, tiefer ist, als dass ich mit den Füßen runterkomme und, ähm,
ich nicht sehe, wie tief es geht.
Also, ich bin zum Beispiel öfters früher am Baggersee gewesen und habe mich dann auf die Luftmatratze gelegt,
oder ein bisschen rumgepaddelt, weil ich habe mich nicht getraut, ähm,
über den See zu schwimmen.
Ich habe da permanent gedacht, da sind irgendwelche komischen mutierten Fische drin oder sowas.
Fragt mich nicht.
Man denkt sich ja die bescheuertsten Sachen aus, wenn man, wenn man Schiss vor irgendwas hat.
Äh, und, deswegen, das mag ich nicht.
Und ich habe dann irgendwann gemerkt, dass wenn du, wenn ich so auf der, auf der Luftmatratze rumgepaddelt bin,
dann, da guckst du so ins Wasser und man sieht ja nichts.
Also, wenn man von der Luftmatratze in den Baggersee reinguckt, du siehst ja nichts, das spiegelt ja wie Sau.
Und ich habe mir immer eingebildet, dass unter mir irgendwelche riesigen, äh, gefährlichen Fische rum,
also im Prinzip waren das eigentlich nur Spiegelungen auf der Oberfläche.
Das war mir klar.
Da haben sich irgendwelche Bäume drin gespiegelt oder sonst was.
Aber ich habe dann ins Wasser runtergeguckt von der Luftmatratze und habe gedacht,
da wären irgendwelche riesen gefährlichen Viecher unter mir und sowas.
Weil ich es halt nicht gesehen habe im Wasser.
Darf ich den Link posten über den, kannst du ruhig machen.
Fisch KI, die Fisch KI ist am Start.
Schau mal in das, was gibt es?
Gibt es echt sowas?
How I imagine deep water.
Ja, genau das.
Ohne Scheiß.
Das, das trifft es genau.
MonkaS.
Exakt so stelle ich mir tiefes Wasser vor.
Ist ohne Scheiß, ist so.
Ist...
Sieht übelst zum fürchten aus, Alter.
Wahrscheinlich wirkt es auf mich jetzt so, weil ich mich da auch besonders gut reinversetzen kann, ja.
Ja.
Kommt heute Teil 2 von dem hier, weiß ich nicht, was war denn das?
Moment, was ist das?
Ach, das ist wohl schon mal Poxmox ausprobiert habe.
Moment, was habe ich da gemacht?
What?
The fuck?
Hä?
Max?
Was?
Hä?
Das habe ich jetzt nicht kapiert.
Was habe ich da gemacht?
Hä?
Ich habe mich eingeloggt und direkt rebooted.
Da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Nee, das waren wir heute nicht.
Naja, so.
Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Wenn man jetzt quasi sagt, ich downloade mal das aktuelle Poxmox, ne?
In der Zwischenzeit.
Wenn man sowas hat und sagt, hey, ich will jetzt tauchen lernen oder so.
Und sagt, ja, okay, vielleicht kann man das irgendwie überwinden.
Vollkommen in Ordnung, ja.
So, aber irgendwann, während das runter lädt, kann ich das mal kurz fertig sagen.
Aber irgendwann muss man halt wirklich mal so in sich gehen und sich halt überlegen,
okay, manche Sachen gehören halt einfach zu einem dabei, ne?
Ich habe mal irgendwann festgestellt, dass ich andere Menschen nicht mag.
So.
Das habe ich aber nie bewusst festgestellt, bis ich mir da mal Gedanken drüber gemacht habe.
Zum Beispiel, warum ich nie auf Weihnachtsfeiern gehe und sowas.
Ich hasse andere Menschen.
Vor allem, wenn ich sie nicht kenne.
Und die meisten, die ich kenne, mag ich auch nicht.
Außer natürlich, ihr wisst ja, den Chat.
Der Chat, Chat außen vor, ja.
Und das sind so Sachen, da muss man sich erstmal selbst im Klaren drüber werden,
warum man manche Sachen macht.
Ich habe mich immer davor gedrückt, auf die Weihnachtsfeier zu gehen, auf irgendwelche Veranstaltungen zu gehen oder sonst was.
Ähm.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich, warum ich auf Weihnachtsfeiern gehe und sowas, ist zum Essen.
Ja.
Habe ich euch schon mal erzählt, wo ich auf der, auf der, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
ähm, also schon eine ganze Weile her, also irgendwo 2008, 7, 8 oder so,
habe ich euch mal erzählt, wo ich es da mal zwischenmenschlich so, ähm,
komplett, was heißt, absolut nicht verstanden habe und voll verkackt habe.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe.
Da.
Also, da war ich, da war ich ja selbst noch, da war ich ja selbst noch Azubi.
Mit dem Grill, genau, Nico.
Mit dem Grill und der Bahn, okay, ich habe es schon erzählt, ich habe es schon erzählt.
Ich, ich habe es schon, ich habe es schon erzählt, ja.
Zumindest, ich, für all die Lichter bei mir, während das Ganze runter lädt.
Und wir machen, wir machen, ach, ich habe schon runter geladen.
Wir machen jetzt nebenbei noch den USB-Stick davon, ähm.
Und während, während der USB-Stick brennt, dann, ähm.
erzähle ich da. Nein, nein, nicht das
Weihnachtsgrill, Leute. Das Weihnachtsgrill,
das ist zwei Jahre her oder ein Jahr oder so.
Ne, zwei, zwei. Weiß ich schon gar nicht
mehr genau. Äh, so.
Also, wir machen mal kurz den USB-Stick
in der Zwischenzeit. Ne.
Also, was ich da verkackt hab, war folgendes.
Übrigens, ich zeig euch mal absolut
High-End, High-End, ähm,
SSD, die ich noch gefunden hab, die wir
heute zum Installieren verwenden. Warte mal.
Absolut High-End ist es.
32G SSD
von vor 15 Jahren oder so.
Uralt.
Uralt. Na, 15 ja nicht. Von vor 10 Jahren
oder so. Uralt.
Gab's nicht auch mal... Oh, erinnere mich nicht
da dran, Sir Banjo. Erinnere mich nicht da dran.
Sir Banjo,
das ist ein Thema. Hör mal bloß
auf. Das
Minecraft-Grill, das war
echt problematisch.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Das, das...
Nein, nein, die mein ich nicht. So, hat er jetzt
erkannt, dass ich die
SSD angeschlossen hab?
Moment.
Was ist denn die... Was ist denn die richtige?
Ah, hier. Das war doch
die richtige. Okay.
Wusste ich nicht, genau.
So, also Flash from File,
Downloads, ähm,
genau, und während das flasht, kann ich das von
der Weihnachtsfeier erzählen, wo ich's richtig
schön verschissen hab.
Wo ist es denn? Proximox?
Ach, stimmt. Bin ja bescheuert. Ich hab das
vorhin schon geflasht. Muss das gar nicht...
Komm, wir flashen's jetzt einfach nochmal.
Eigentlich muss ich nicht flashen.
Ich hab das vorhin ja schon geflasht.
Egal. Da kann ich jetzt wenigstens was erzählen
in der Zwischenzeit. Wir flashen jetzt einfach nochmal.
Exzellent.
So, und zwar auf der Weihnachtsfeier,
damals, wo ich dort, wo ich noch, wie gesagt,
beim Provider gearbeitet hab, ähm,
da gab's, äh,
also wie gesagt, ich war noch Azubi,
und, wie gesagt, ich war Azubi in
Frankfurt, und der Provider war in einer anderen Stadt
in Deutschland, also es war eine ganze Ecke weg.
Allerdings aus diesem Grund bin ich da nicht gerne hingefahren.
Aber auf die Weihnachtsfeier
und so bin ich, bin ich, damals hab ich mich da ab und zu
noch gezwungen, und da hab ich's,
halt, richtig verkackt. Und zwar gab's da auch
eine Auszubildende,
die, ähm, wir haben uns eigentlich,
also ich, ich, ich, ich,
ich würd's mal so beschreiben, wir haben uns
eigentlich von Anfang an irgendwie gemocht, ja.
Und ich war ja
nicht oft da an diesem Standort,
aber, ähm, wenn ich denn da war,
das waren wir dann auch ab und zu Mittagessen
und sonst was, also wir haben uns eigentlich wirklich gut verstanden.
Und, und man hat auch, so
im Nachhinein, ja, so wenn ich mal,
wenn ich mal so, so in mich gehe,
muss ich sagen, man hat das, man
hat's auch im Nachhinein irgendwie gemerkt,
dass, dass wir, glaub ich, beiz-,
ups, sorry, ähm,
beidseitig ein bisschen verknallt ineinander gewesen sind.
So, und
an der Weihnachtsfeier,
äh, Weihnachtsfeier,
keine Ahnung, fragt mich nicht, irgendwie 23 Uhr, irgendwas,
ähm, die Leute sind grad angefangen,
ultra besoffen zu werden.
Ist sie auf einmal zu mir gekommen
und hat gefragt, ähm,
ob ich sie nicht heimbringen kann,
beziehungsweise, ob ich sie nicht zum Zug begleiten kann,
ob ich sie nicht zum Zug bringen kann, sie will nicht alleine laufen,
und so.
Und ich bin halt so richtig dämlich gewesen,
ich hab's damals nicht gecheckt.
Ich hab's, ich hab's
komplett,
komplett nicht kapiert, ja.
So richtig,
richtig
bescheuert. Zumindest, ähm,
hab ich schon gesagt, ja klar, kann ich machen,
ja, kein, kein, kein Ding.
Und, ähm,
ah ne, viel, viel mehr kommt da jetzt nicht.
Also, da kommt jetzt nix ultra zum
Fremdschämen, aber ich hab's, ich hab's insofern verkackt,
ich hab gesagt, ja, können wir machen, äh,
ich zieh, ich zieh mich schnell an, und ich hab's
damals auch schon gar nicht gecheckt.
Die hat schon versucht, quasi so möglichst schnell
da abzuhauen, ja, und so auch, dass es kaum
jemand mitkriegt.
Und, ähm, ich bin dann mit raus, so,
und irgendwann, äh, waren wir draußen
und da standen halt noch ein paar andere Leute,
und
da sind wir halt so Richtung Bahnhof gelaufen, irgendwann sind
es ja noch ein paar andere von der Firma entgegengekommen,
und da meinte halt noch so einer, ja, ja, er muss jetzt
auch zum Bahnhof, er kann da mit, äh, und, und
schon gucken. Und da hab ich dann gesagt, ja, okay,
alles gut, macht's gut, ich geh ins Hotel.
So richtig, so richtig dumm, äh.
Eigentlich hätt ich sagen müssen,
nee, natürlich bring ich dich noch zum Bahnhof, und dann
noch irgendwie ein bisschen schwätzen unterwegs
und sagen, ja, wollen wir vielleicht irgendwie sonst wie noch,
oder, äh.
Aber,
Massive Pains Champ.
Richtig verkackt. Also,
im Nachhinein betrachtet war das eigentlich alles
sehr offensichtlich, aber
der Max hat's nicht verstanden.
So, hat das
jetzt, hat das Ganze jetzt eigentlich fertig gebrannt?
Gebrannt, Alter.
Ihr seht doch mal, wie mich so Themen schon wieder
verwirren, äh, gebrannt, geflasht.
Chat, wie lang
ist es her, dass ihr zuletzt
was gebrannt habt?
Mentos BFH sagt, du warst kurz vor den Jungen,
bist dann von der Map gesprungen.
So könnte man's umschreiben, ja.
Paar Jahre, okay.
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich euch da grad frag,
was habt, was geht
mit der Musik ab?
Ähm, wo wir grad beim Thema sind,
ich hab euch ja grad gefragt, wann ihr zuletzt ein CD gebrannt habt.
Wann hab ich euch denn eigentlich zuletzt,
schon mal meine Heizungsüberwachung
gezeigt und wie gut die funktioniert?
Ich glaube, das ist schon
eine ganze Weile her. Man sieht hier auch wieder,
wie schön man unten erkennt, wie die Pumpe
läuft, wie der Brenner angeht und die
Heizungstemperatur im Durchschnitt, Abgas, Kessel,
Status.
Ich glaub, das ist bestimmt schon zwei Jahre her,
wo ich euch das gezeigt hab, oder?
Merci vielmals.
Hast du sie danach überhaupt wieder gesehen?
Ja, ähm,
ja und nee, also nur mal
kurz und ich hab's,
wie gesagt, ich hab's, ich hab's erst mal
überhaupt nicht gecheckt und danach hab ich's eigentlich
auch weiter verkackt und, ähm,
leider
war die mit ihrer
Ausbildung mehr oder weniger,
frag mich nicht, März oder so, dann fertig.
Und ich
wollte sie noch am letzten Tag anrufen,
ich wollte sie noch am letzten Tag anrufen,
als ich die Mail gesehen hab.
Ich hab die Mail gesehen, ähm,
irgendwie so eine Abschluss-Mail,
so nach dem Motto, hat ihre Ausbildung beendet
und als ich die Mail gesehen hab,
wollte ich instant anrufen und auch fragen,
keine Ahnung, äh, eine Handynummer,
falls ich mal wieder da bin oder irgendwas in der Richtung,
keine Ahnung, so, das war ich, weil das war so die letzte
Chance, die ich hätte
nutzen können und
ja, und dann war das Telefon schon abgemeldet.
Pippe-Hands!
Hahaha.
Nee, also da ist nichts mehr passiert danach.
Eigentlich richtig dämlich.
So, ähm, muss der SSD
abziehen.
F, ja.
So, dann stöpseln wir mal diese
High-End-SSD. Leute,
die SSD ist übel schwer.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die damals noch irgendwie
fünffach Layer Flash reingemacht haben
oder so.
Kann man überhaupt von einer SSD
installieren mit so einem
USB-Adapter? Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Stöpseln wir mal kurz dran.
Ah ja, und dann muss ich, oh fuck,
ich hab meine Tastatur wieder den Knopf abgemacht.
Ich hab ihn immer noch
festgeklebt.
Dann müssen wir mal kurz Game Capture
HD aufmachen und gucken,
ob die Verbindung zu der Kiste
da oben in der Ecke funktioniert.
Wartet mal, checken wir grad mal schnell.
Ah, yes.
Exzellent.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Jetzt muss bloß noch die SSD dran...
Was macht der da gerade?
Sollte der jetzt nicht einfach nur anzeigen,
äh, keine Platte gefunden
oder sowas?
Ähm, Teddy Kupp
fragt, ich will mir ein eigenes NAS bauen.
Free NAS oder Open Media Vault?
Ganz ehrlich, nachdem ich das
gestern ausprobiert hab, nehm das hier.
Beste.
Hat mir um, also,
Open Media Vault hat mir gar nicht gefallen, Free NAS ist ganz okay.
Hat mir um Längen besser gefallen
als alles andere. Das ist das
Synology-Betriebssystem,
was du aber selbst auf deiner
eigenen Hardware installieren kannst.
Also, ich bin ja selten begeistert
von irgendwas, aber da muss ich echt sagen,
vom Funktionsumfang her
und auch wie einheitlich das Ganze zu bedienen
ist, kann ich das nur jedem
halbwegs versierten,
selbst Bastler empfehlen, sich den
Kram draufzuhauen.
Ob das jetzt so zuverlässig
ist wie ein Free NAS mit ZFS,
wenn du da spezielle Anforderungen hast, sei mal dahingestellt,
aber wenn du kein ZFS haben willst,
nehm das hier.
Da hast du auch alles, was du brauchst, eingebaut.
Von irgendwelchen, ähm,
Fotoverwaltung, Notizverwaltung,
äh,
IP-Cam-Geschichten,
also, falls du das brauchen sollst, wenn nicht, lässt es aus.
Zig Zusatzreduktionen,
Stalker-Container, VMs, alles mögliche über die
GUI drauflaufen lassen. Wenn's dich
interessiert, was man damit machen kann, ich hab's gestern zum ersten Mal
im Stream ausprobiert, kannst dir mal angucken. Also,
ich muss echt sagen, von allen NAS-Systemen, die ich bisher
ausprobiert hab, ist das mit Abstand das Beste.
Also, die Synology-Jungs
wissen, was sie machen.
So, jetzt mal
hier, ne, der mag nicht booten.
Was hat der denn für Schmerzen?
Ich mach mal die SSD dran und guck, ob er dann bootet.
Achtung, liegt, Leute,
liegt.
Äh,
achso,
jetzt muss ich mal erst mal neu starten.
Mal gucken, ob mein Headset-Kabel reicht. Moment, Moment, Moment.
Netzteil aus und dann Netzteil
wieder an.
Dashplayer, Twitch Prime, danke schön. Ich bin
gar nicht am Rechner, sonst würd ich irgendwelche Sounds einspielen.
Danke schön für den Sub. Ich muss erst mal
ins Netzteil dran.
Netzteil.
So.
Gucken, ob's jetzt bootet.
Wenn nicht, muss ich die Tastatur
dran stecken und Boot-Menü auswählen.
Auf geht's.
Was, Proxmox 6.2,
da startet die ZDF?
Ah, da ist es doch.
Excellent.
Achso, ja gut, die Tastatur muss ich jetzt trotzdem
anschließen.
Kann man in Xpenology auch einen JDownloader?
Klar, du kannst ja ein vollständiges,
ähm, du kannst ja eine vollständige Shell holen.
Also, JDownloader
selbst hab ich nicht nachgeschaut.
Ich hab aber gesehen, dass es im
Community-Repo, ähm,
Custom Addons gibt für
Downloader, von Torrent bis sonst was,
aber JDownloader bestimmt auch.
Aber ansonsten kannst du es garantiert irgendwie nachinstallieren.
Und spätestens, dass du
Docker-Container laufen lassen kannst,
kannst du eh alles drinnen machen, was du willst.
Ähm, so.
Ich mach mal hier Fullscreen, dass man
ordentlich was sieht.
So, und jetzt muss ich die Tastatur umstöpseln.
Moment.
Achso.
Alter, warum steckt mein USB immer falsch rum rein?
Kennt ihr das? USB ist
prinzipiell falsch rum.
Max, hol dir doch ein KVM
Spider, hab ich.
Hab ich sogar.
Ähm, hab ich.
Ich weiß bloß grad nicht, wo.
Hab ich.
Damit kann man über den Browser die Sache
fernsteuern. Hab ich.
Okay.
Gucken, ob das Steuern jetzt funktioniert. Ja, passt.
Install.
Windows 10 über SSH zu bedienen ist grausam,
kann ich mir vorstellen.
Man konnte dein Gesicht im Fingernagel...
Der war gut.
So.
Also, Installer.
Okay. Ah!
Moment. Brauch ich jetzt wirklich die Maus dafür?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Das geht doch bestimmt auch so.
Brauch ich da die Maus für?
Ich komm, ich komm nicht auf das
Acree.
Ich brauch da die Maus für, oder?
Also, Tab geht nicht und Alt-Tab geht nicht.
Also, weder noch.
Okay, dann hol ich mal ne Maus.
Ich hab ja, also Mäuse hab ich genug, bloß Tastatur nicht.
Was? Es gibt eine Spezial...
Okay, na gut.
Jetzt zu spät.
Ha.
Oh, die Maus ist übelst verstaubt und klebt.
Die lag, die lag ewig rum.
Okay.
Wie Acree.
Excel. So, und jetzt kann ich bestimmt mit Tastatur machen, hä?
Ach, jetzt...
Das ist ja bescheuert.
Warum kann ich denn jetzt mit Tastatur bedienen,
aber vorher nicht?
Das ist doch doof.
Kann die Kamera eigentlich umfallen und dich leaken?
Sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass die einfach umfällt.
Okay, wahrscheinlich muss ich ja einfach jetzt weiter machen, hm?
Germany. Jawoll.
Warum lassen die mich das am Anfang denn nur mit der Maus klicken?
Und jetzt mit der Tastatur.
Das ist irgendwie auch ein bisschen widersprüchlich.
Passwort.
Mail at example.invalid.
Excellent. Perfekt.
Woher kennen die meine E-Mail-Adresse?
Ach. Mail
at
blblblblblblblblblblblblblblblblb
Ey, wir machen das anders.
Example.com ist schon okay.
lolw at example.com
Und wir können auch local aus...
Aber example.com ist okay.
Example.com ist per RFC
Testdomain, da geht nix.
So, also pve-example.fqdn
Ja, das ist okay.
Wie der fqdn heißt mir...
Wahrscheinlich darf ich aber nicht, punkt example.
Okay, dann machen wir mal pve.
Dann haben wir mal die legit-Domain.
Gateway, alles klar.
DNS-Server, alles klar.
Next.
Wenn die Kamera umfällt, springe ich oder mein Schreibtisch.
Dann sieht mich keiner.
Insta.
Und wenn man mich sieht, es gibt Schlimmeres.
Ich will bloß das nicht groß irgendwo zeigen, weil ich keinen Bock habe, dass...
Was geht mit der Maus ab?
Dass mich irgendwelche Leute im Zug erkennen oder so.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wenn ich mal irgendwo...
Es gab schon Events, wo mich Leute gefilmt haben.
Jetzt hat halt keiner bis auf wenige gecheckt, dass ich das bin.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Das handelt so wenige...
Kobold-Stream an Weihnachten.
So, mal gucken, wie lange der hier installiert.
Wir müssen ihm ja gar nicht zugucken.
Was erzählt er uns hier eigentlich?
Proxmox Cluster File System PMXCFS.
Also einen kryptischeren Namen hätten wir ja nicht mal verwenden können.
Das ist übrigens eine Sache, die wir später ausprobieren werden.
Angeblich.
Also Proxmox kann ja nur direkt...
Quasi RAW LXC-Virtualisierung.
Aber angeblich kann man mittlerweile da drin auch einen Docker laufen lassen.
Das will ich mal ausprobieren.
Wie gut das funktioniert.
Natürlich kann man immer noch eine VM installieren und darin einen Docker laufen lassen.
Das ist ja keine Frage.
Das geht natürlich auch.
So, bla bla bla bla.
Juckt uns alles nicht.
Pascal-Stream.
Naja, also wir programmieren öfter C-Sharp.
Und in C-Sharp steckt ein bisschen Pascal.
Also allein schon, weil der Pascal...
Moment.
Bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander?
Pascal oder Delphi?
Weil der C-Sharp-Erfinder hat vorher Delphi oder Pascal entwickelt.
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht sicher, ob es Pascal oder Delphi ist.
Ich glaube, Delphi war es, oder?
Wo hat der Heilsberg mit dran entwickelt?
Delphi?
Delphi ist Pascal.
Ja, stimmt.
Deswegen bringe ich es durcheinander.
Ich habe jetzt nicht die Tastatur dran.
Wie gesagt, der Anders Heilsberg ist ja der C-Sharp-Erfinder.
Und der hat vorher, glaube ich, entweder Pascal-Turbo, Pascal-Delphi, irgendwie sowas gemacht.
Und da sind bestimmt ein paar Sachen von auch in C-Sharp mit eingeflossen.
VM in der VM ist nicht so nice.
Naja, es ist nicht VM in der VM.
Es wäre ja dann quasi eine VM auf Metal.
Also auf der Hardware hier.
Und da drin ein Docker.
Also das sollte sich in Grenzen halten, was man da an CPU-Leistung verliert.
Generell muss man ja sagen, die CPU-Leistung...
Also die CPU-Leistung, die man verliert mit Virtualisierung, halten sich in Grenzen.
Also es macht kaum einen Unterschied, ob ich jetzt was auf dem Host...
Also rein CPU-Leistung, ja.
Also wenn ich jetzt mal irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, Primzahlen berechne,
dass irgendwas von der Prime 95 laufen lasse oder so.
Also rein die CPU-Leistung zwischen der VM und dem Host, das ist gar kein so großer Unterschied.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie viel es ist.
Aber mich würde es wundern, wenn es mehr als 5% sind, die man einboosten hat.
Wahrscheinlich ist es mittlerweile bei modernen CPUs mit...
Virtualisierung, Extension und sowas wahrscheinlich unter 1%.
Was man an CPU-Leistung einbüßt bei richtigen VMs.
Die Sache ist nur die, was übrigens meine Maus leckt, übelst, weil meine Capture-Card leckt.
141, also was brauchen wir?
141.8006, okay.
Alles klar, gehen wir gleich hin.
Ja.
Was ist 141.8006?
Was macht ihr das Proxmox-Wiki auf?
Dort findet man das freie Debian-Repository.
Dafür Boxbox.
Sonst erhält man keinerlei Updates über Upget.
Ach.
Warum?
Weil man das Subscription kaufen soll?
Oder...
Oder weil Bug?
Bootet der jetzt?
Toll.
Hat er jetzt gebootet und ich sehe es bloß nicht?
Oder...
Oder was macht der?
Macht der überhaupt was?
Habt ihr gesehen, ob der gebootet hat?
Ah, wegen Subscription, okay.
Ich mach mal kurz Game Capture aus.
Und mach es nochmal an.
Ah, da sind wir doch.
Sehr gut.
Okay, hab ich jetzt die SSD installiert und jetzt ist die SSD verreckt, oder wie?
Das wär's jetzt mal.
SSD installiert, SSD direkt verreckt.
F.
Das kann ich mir jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen.
Naja gut, also 141.8006, ich mach mal kurz meine Tastatur wieder ab.
Und dann gucken wir uns das Ganze an.
Fingerleak.
Jaja, der Max hat dicke Arme und dicke Finger und so.
Das war ja auch mal eine Zeit lang so der Running Gag auf YouTube.
Dicht hinter, wann zeigt die Silvana ihre...
Ja, wir hatten schon viel dummes Zeug da auf YouTube, das war auch geil irgendwo.
So.
Also, wo müssen wir hin?
192.168.2.141 und dann 8006.
Ah, HTTPS.
Lol.
Jaja, kein gültiges Zertifikat, das hab ich mir schon fast gedacht.
Okay, Username.
Okay, Proxmox, Default.
Ach ne, Moment, ich hab doch...
...Root.
Ich hab doch Passwort, vergeben, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Äh, ich hab doch, ich hab doch vergessen.
Ich hab's nur vergessen, was ich grad für ein Passwort eingetippt hab.
Da sind wir doch schon.
You do not have a valid subscription.
Leute, hab ich euch schon erzählt, dass man auf Twitch mit Amazon Prime total einfach eine valid bekommt.
Man kann nämlich einmal im Monat mit Amazon Prime kostenlos einen Streamer seiner Wahl Prime subscriben.
Kostet euch überhaupt gar nix.
Ja, und hier müsst ihr eine Lizenz kaufen.
Okay.
Dann, dann doch lieber Twitch Prime machen.
You do not have a valid subscription.
Okay.
Also, das heißt...
...Wiki Proxmox.
Und was soll denn...
Ach, was hat...
Irgendjemand im Chat hat grad gesagt...
Ach, was ich gucken soll.
Ach, hier.
Package Repo.
Crash Fluffy, drei Monate in die Abo-Fahle.
Exzellent, dankeschön.
No subscription repo.
This repository for testing and non-production...
Das ist mal sowas von kein Production News, was ich hier mache.
Das Kind Icaros Musik?
Ne, Smash...
Fast.
Ne, eigentlich gar nicht.
So, also.
So, wie ändere ich das jetzt?
Also, wie gesagt, ich hab das noch nie wirklich als Hauptsystem verwendet.
Das heißt, ich kenn mich damit nicht wirklich gut aus.
Also.
Wo könnte man hier jetzt Package Updates einladen?
Options, hä?
Kennt hier jemand Icinga?
Das ist, äh, Nagios.
Ich, äh, ich mag...
Ich persönlich mag Nagios.
Aber, äh, viele andere mögen Nagios nicht.
Shell.
Aha.
Kann man da rein Copy-Pasten?
Oh, ne.
Wie macht man SSH an?
Hier kann man nicht Copy-Pasten, oder?
MonkaS.
No Copy-Paste.
So, wir gehen jetzt erstmal kurz auf Linux und machen das unter Linux.
So, weil ich hab keinen Bock, das unter Windows zu machen.
Gut.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Bam.
Gut.
Ist, ist SSH standardmäßig schon an?
Gucken wir mal.
Gut.
Add.
Okay.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir machen jetzt die Easy-Variante.
What?
Äh.
Ich mein, ich kann den Key löschen, aber...
What?
Warum?
Wisst ihr was?
Ich lösch einfach das komplette File, weil ich brauch den ganzen...
Ich seh nicht.
So.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Da sind wir.
Sehr schön.
So, und jetzt, Update geht so nicht.
Ach, tatsächlich.
Update geht so nicht.
Ja, ich hab schon einen Eintrag, aber ich hab gesagt, kein House-Key-Checking.
Das sollte ihn dann eigentlich nicht jucken.
Okay, ich darf wirklich nicht drauf zugreifen.
So, das heißt, ich geh jetzt ETC, Upt.
Und dann, wo gehen wir hin, dass man die Repos eintragen kann?
Äh, machen wir hier zu.
Package, Repos.
Erstmal kurz umgruppieren auf mein Linux.
Ähm.
Ab-Sources-List.
Kein Wim drauf.
Okay, aber ein VI.
VI ist überall drauf.
So, schmeißen wir den Kram raus.
Und nun, das da.
Hä?
Moment, das stand da doch schon drinnen.
Ah, die...
Ach, das einzige...
Das einzige ist das da, was man eintragen muss.
Der Rest kann da drin stehen bleiben.
Lull.
So.
Okay, jetzt Update.
Und dann...
Unauthorized.
Reboot?
Nee.
Meinst du?
Einen Reboot muss man da normalerweise nicht für machen.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal das Wichtigste.
Wir installieren es in Wim nach.
Ich meine, das ist ja unter der Hauben ein Stück normales Debian.
Ach so, ja.
Es kann sein, dass die alten noch hier drunter stehen.
ETC, Upt.
Sources.
List.
Ah, guck mal, die stehen noch hier drin.
Die muss man wahrscheinlich rausmachen.
Guckt.
Und jetzt funktioniert es.
Ähm.
So, äh, kann man die Updates über das Webinterface machen?
Das ist jetzt das Nächste.
Erstmal.
Nicht spoilern, Chat.
Also als erstes, ich will mal die Schrift ein bisschen größer machen.
Siehst ja kaum was.
Aber jetzt ist viel zu fett.
So, Updates.
Hier.
Okay, das kann man übrigens schön über die Oberfläche machen.
Gut ist.
Exzellent.
Also das ist quasi...
...mehr oder weniger ein Webfrontend für Upd-Upgrade.
Upgrade.
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Oh, ach, das macht mir einen Remote, das macht mir eine VNC.
Moment mal, das muss ich mir jetzt...
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
Das macht mir eine Shell auf, dass ich dem Upgrade zugucken kann.
Okay.
Aber was hat der?
XtermJS Spice?
Spice habe ich nicht installiert.
Aber Spice kann ich installieren.
Ähm, dazu brauchen wir den Wirt Viewer.
Das weiß ich, seit ich da mal ewig gesucht habe, was man dafür...
Oh Mann.
Ich müsste jetzt auch noch Betriebssystem-Update machen, da habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Ne, das lassen wir jetzt.
Aber wir lassen den mal im Hintergrund updaten.
So, ähm...
So, was hat der noch?
No VNC, können wir auch machen.
Okay.
Dann machen wir es lieber da drüber.
Hä?
Is locked by another process.
Warum?
Wie ist locked?
Okay, das funkt ja schon...
Geht schon mal gut los.
Achso, man kann...
Ne, dann macht er die Shell auf.
Ach, jetzt funktioniert es.
Okay, yes, alles klar.
Mach Update.
Das hätten wir auch direkt...
Oh, jetzt hat es mich verwirrt.
Das sind Updates von meinem Manjaro und das sind Updates von Proxmox.
Auf geht's, Proxmox.
Gib Gas.
Die Kiste oben rechts übrigens ist nichts sonderlich Tolles.
Das ist, ähm...
Ein Dual-Core-Low-Power-Celeron.
Also, da muss man jetzt nicht...
Die wahnsinnige Ultra...
Krase Leistung von erwarten.
So, während es hier upgradet, können wir uns mal angucken, was da sonst noch ist.
So, Syslog kann man sich angucken.
Das ist relativ uninteressant.
Außer, dass die SSD irgendwie kaputt ist.
Äh, Time.
Ja.
Stimmt.
Host-Einträge.
Erwägt mir jetzt ein bisschen RAW, dass man da einfach einen Text-Editor hingeschmissen kriegt.
Aber okay.
DNS-Server, alles klar, richtig.
Zertifikate.
Ach, hier kann man...
Ach, das ist die Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate.
Die Let's Encrypt...
Ähm...
Geschichte?
Äh, wie bediene ich das jetzt?
Wo würde ich denn da jetzt...
Wo würde ich da jetzt beispielsweise meine Cloudflare-Sachen hinterlegen?
Gibt kein Plugin.
This field is required, aber man kann nichts auswählen.
Excellent.
Vielleicht muss ich einen Account anlegen.
Name, lulw.
E-Mail-Adresse, lulw.
Dann muss ich da registrieren?
Habe ich...
Ich musste mich noch nie registrieren?
Wie registrieren bei Let's Encrypt?
Man muss seine E-Mail-Adresse angeben.
Und selbst das kann man skippen.
Und dann ist gut?
Hä?
Okay, das braucht weitere Investigation.
So, jetzt müssen wir rebooten.
Wie rebootet man über die Oberfläche?
Wir haben Update gemacht und jetzt wollen wir rebooten.
Ich meine, klar, ich kann es über die Shell machen.
Aber es gibt da bestimmt einen Reboot-Knopf.
Ach, hier oben, Reboot.
Excellent.
Yes.
Dann können wir hier zugucken, wie er rebootet.
Und ich glaube, die SSD ist echt kaputt jetzt.
Moin, Leib-Boomster.
Die SSD hat wirklich installiert und jetzt ist er im Arsch.
Können wir ihm auch mal beim Booten zugucken.
What?
Oh, ich habe schon gedacht, der hängt jetzt in der Boot-Loop oder so und ist kaputt.
Nee, ist er nicht.
Hat funktioniert, der ist wieder da.
Da ist er.
Zusammenfassung.
Proxmox.
Wir haben gerade erst fertig installiert und ich habe Updates gemacht, sonst nichts.
So, Disks.
Jetzt probieren wir mal, ob ich die zweite SSD irgendwie eingehängt kriege, als was
auch immer, zum Testen.
Initialize this with GPT.
Alles klar, machen wir.
Okay.
Und jetzt?
Ihr seid mal ernsthaft?
Ist die SSD gerade verreckt nach der Installation?
Es sieht echt so aus.
Die hat die Installation noch gemacht und jetzt ist es kaputt.
Geil.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich meine, wir können auch von Hand das Ganze überschreiben.
Ich will mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Create ZFS.
Ist das nicht so, dass es standardmäßig ZFS ist?
Was?
16 GB ist nur frei?
Moment.
What?
Der will mir doch nicht erzählen, dass er so viel für das System braucht.
Ach, der teilt das auf.
Okay, zeige ich mal her.
Root 55.
Ja, aber wo ist der Rest?
Wo ist der Rest?
Root hat 55.
Was ist SDA?
Ach so, das sehe ich bloß an der Stelle wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oh, wie das Platoon Musik.
Excellent.
So, dann machen wir jetzt mal was anderes.
Also, wenn der wirklich der Meinung ist.
Meine zweite SSD...
What the fuck?
Ich glaube das nicht, dass die SSD unmittelbar nach der Installation verreckt ist.
Das glaube ich dem nicht.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Der Zufall wäre zu groß.
Ich stöpsel es ab und mache es nochmal dran.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ja, machen wir nochmal ab.
Andere USB-Anschlüsse sind da dran.
Das glaube ich dem nicht, dass die SSD verreckt ist.
Ah, jetzt ist sie da.
Guck.
Easy.
Jetzt geht alles.
Hast wohl einmal zu oft geflasht, ja.
So, Usage Partitions.
Wie kann ich die jetzt verwenden als Storage?
Was ist denn da überhaupt drauf?
Hat er das schon gemountet irgendwo?
Ne.
Ach so, das ist das Installationsmedium.
Genau.
Ähm.
The Yenna hat...
Ach ne, ich habe gehört du hast das subscribed.
Ne, du hast einen Timeout gekriegt.
Excellent.
Ähm.
Wie kann ich dem jetzt sagen, dass ich das als Storage verwenden will für irgendwas?
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Rechts.
Scheint komplizierter zu sein, als ich mir das vorstelle.
Jetzt timeouten sie sich alle.
Reload.
Hä?
Wie sage ich ihm, dass ich die Disc verwende?
Der Timeout ist real im Chat, Alter.
Exquisite Timeout.
Okay, ich bin zu blöd dafür, dem zu sagen, dass er die Festplatte verwenden soll.
What the fuck?
Hm.
Gut.
Dann ignorieren wir das jetzt mal.
Wir testen jetzt mal das eigentlich Wichtige.
Wir legen eine VM an.
Und dann probieren wir mal das Neue aus.
Nämlich einen Docker laufen lassen.
Ehm.
LXC.
Und dann gucken wir, wie das mit Pass-through ist mit der 10 Gigabit-Karte.
Also, falls irgendwer noch eine Ahnung hat, wie ich den überreden kann, meine 32G SSD zu verwenden.
Dann sag Bescheid.
Du kriegst so einen Timeout, wenn du selbst Timeout für Points gemacht hast.
Oder, wenn sich der Mod verklickt hat, weil sich gerade 30.000 Leute getimeoutet haben.
Welcher Mod ist gerade da und timeoutet?
Es ist ja toll, dass die Leute hier Punkte für Timeout ausgeben.
Excellent.
So, ähm.
Also, jetzt legen wir mal eine VM an.
Nodes braucht keiner.
Keckweh.
Excellent.
Noch nicht mal Markdown.
Lull.
Das mit dem Timeout geht übrigens nur, wenn ein Mod da ist.
Also, legen wir mal eine VM an.
Storage.
Ach, hier kann man das verwenden.
Oder, hier kann man das wahrscheinlich auswählen.
Nee.
OK, dann, dann plicki ich's nicht.
Also, also, wir erstellen mal.
Man kann VM erstellen und wir können Container erstellen.
Wir erstellen einfach mal eine VM.
Sowas ganz easy.
Name.
Ubuntu VM.
So, Resource Pool.
Pool.
Nee.
Ach, nee, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach, nur wenn man dann, irgendwie, was restriktiv,
Restriktion machen will, denke ich mal.
Oh, das enttäuscht mich jetzt ein bisschen, dass der nicht direkt Isos downloaden kann.
Kannst du auch Templates verwenden?
Wo gibt es Templates?
Okay, die Playlist geht mir voll auf den Keks.
Da ist zu viel Splatoon-Musik drin.
Lull Arms.
Arms ist auch so eine Totgeburt von Nintendo gewesen.
Die haben ja sogar angekündigt, dass es eine Arms-E-Sport-League gibt.
Und, ähm, gab es nie.
Okay, dann installieren wir jetzt mal noch VM.
Ich weiß, ich will ja auch eine KVM-VM erstellen.
Ich dachte aber, der kann vielleicht Isos downloaden.
Das wäre mal richtig gut gewesen.
Das wäre einfacher gewesen.
Aber guck mal, ich habe eine Idee.
Wir können über PXE starten.
Ich habe PXE bei mir am Start.
Do not use any media.
Mal gucken, ob das mit PXE funktioniert.
Next.
Ja, ja, passt alles.
Default.
Harddrive.
Wir lassen mal alles.
Alles Default.
Next.
CPU.
Eins.
Ja, passt.
Memory.
Ist auch okay.
Das Ding hat übrigens, das System hat übrigens kaum Speicher, ne?
Das ist übelst low-end.
Äh.
Ah, na, okay.
8G.
Ist auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Das Interface sieht aber genauso aus wie bei Synology.
Da dachte ich, ne, finde ich nicht.
Synology sah viel bunter und, ähm, äh, bisschen verspielter aus, so als das.
Was ist heute Thema Ziel?
Das, einfach das neue Proxmox angucken.
Next.
Network.
Network Bridge.
Wunderbar.
Ich hoffe, das geht damit.
Dass ich, äh, müsste eigentlich gehen, dass ich direkt ans Netzwerk komme und PXE-Boot machen kann.
Confirm.
So, jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Macht er standardmäßig EFI oder BIOS?
Data Center Storage Add Directory.
Ja, das, äh, dann sagt er mir aber, dass keine Disk frei ist.
Das habe ich schon ausprobiert.
So, jetzt habe ich eine VM angelegt.
Wo stehen die VMs jetzt drin?
Äh.
Moment, wo finde ich meine VMs?
Ach, da.
Okay, kapiert.
So, und jetzt muss ich gucken, ob das BIOS oder P, äh, oder EFI ist, weil EFI kann ich kein PXE-Boot machen.
Wobei, wir probieren es einfach raus.
So, Hardware.
BIOS.
Exzellent.
Start.
Console.
Da sind wir.
Können wir nämlich direkt EFI-Boot machen.
Muss ich gar kein ISO downloaden oder sowas.
Ist diese Frage sinnlos?
Nein, diese Frage ist.
Exzellent.
Kann man Vollbild machen?
Console.
Spice.
Warum kann ich kein Spice machen?
Durch das extern Öffnen kann man eigentlich auch ganz praktisch.
Du wartest immer noch auf den PXE-Stream.
Der PXE-Stream ist ziemlich, äh, äh, kurz, ne?
Ich, ich starte einen Container und gut ist.
Also das ist total easy.
Du musst einfach den hier nehmen.
Okay, ich mach, ich mach, gleich, gleich mach ich ne andere Playlist.
Der Typ hat ja jedes zweite Lied irgendeine Splatoon-Werbung, äh, Splatoon-Musik.
Du nimmst einfach den Container, startest den und schon geht PXE-Boot.
Achso, ähm, eins musst du nur machen.
Du musst den Server, auf dem du den Container laufen hast, in deinem DHCP eintragen als Next-Server.
Das ist aber auch alles.
Mehr musst du nicht machen.
So, äh, Linux-Installs.
Und zwar ein Ubuntu-Installer.
Install, jawoll.
Guck mal hier, das geht ja richtig flott heute.
Der deutsche Mirror hat, äh, busy, busy, zugelegt, ja.
Letztes Mal war das, war der deutsche Ubuntu-Mirror so unglaublich langsam.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt, das zu installieren.
Ich würde jetzt eigentlich lieber die Docker-Geschichte.
Wir können das, wir können das nebenbei laufen lassen.
Was, was Vollbild ist?
Ah, das ist ne VNC.
Das ist ja so der Standard, Standard-VNC-Ding.
Okay, wir sind Freedom, alles klar.
PXE-Boot geht nur, wenn man den DHCP-Server kontrolliert.
Ja.
Also, du musst im PXE, du musst im DHCP den, ähm, PXE-Server als Next-Server eintragen, sonst geht das nicht.
Yes, wir haben einen Ö-Key, alles klar.
Wir haben keinen E-Key.
Wir haben German-No-Dead-Keys, jawoll.
So, und während das läuft, machen wir, machen wir uns schon mal ne, ne, Container.
Weil angeblich kann man mittlerweile, äh,
Docker im LXC-Container von Proxmox laufen lassen.
So, Test-VM.
Einen DHCP-Proxy kannst du auch machen, ja.
Wobei, wenn du das, äh, alles machst, ist halt die Frage, warum du das machen kannst, aber keinen Zugriff auf den DHCP hast.
Kann man von dem PXE-Server auch Windows booten?
Ja, kann man machen.
Du musst bloß nen...
Also, ich hab's noch nicht gemacht, aber es ist eingebaut.
Ich glaub, du musst nen Windows-ISO entpacken auf dem PXE-Server, weil die das sonst nicht direkt können.
Irgendwie so.
So, okay.
Während der Kram jetzt installiert, machen wir das hier mal wieder zu, und dann legen wir mal hier nen Container an.
Kann man da...
Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz...
What?
Was war das denn?
Your Tab has crashed.
Ist klar ver...
Ach, weil ich im Hintergrund Update mache, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das ist, weil ich im Hintergrund Update mache.
Na gut.
Dann muss das Tab jetzt funktionieren, solange.
So, also, jetzt können wir einen Container anlegen.
Was haben die hier denn zur Auswahl?
Hostname, Omega, 0, äh, Resource Pool, Passwort 123456, SSH, Public Key, brauchen wir nen Template, Storage...
Okay, ich muss nen Template auswählen, aber es gibt keine, keine vorinstallierten Templates?
Du musst zuerst Templates runterladen, okay?
Mach ich.
Okay.
Name von neuer User, Max.
Jawoll.
123456, wir machen überall nur die besten Passwörter.
Okay, andere Playlist.
Der Typ hat mir zu viel Splatoon-Musik drinne.
Da krieg ich, krieg ich, äh, Anfälle.
Das halt ich nicht, das halt ich auf die Dauer wirklich nicht aus.
Calm, calm and happy Nintendo Music.
Excellent.
So.
Sehr gut.
Äh, wo...
Wie, das Passwort ist doch gut, das ist doch nicht weak.
Correct time zone.
Yes.
Okay, während er jetzt installiert, gucken wir, wo wir uns Templates runterladen müssen.
Ich glaube, ich muss noch zweimal OK drücken, im Installer, bis er anfängt.
Muss ihm sagen, dass er All Discs verwenden soll, genau.
Und dann fängt er, glaube ich, jetzt an, runterzuladen, klar.
Sollte er zumindest.
Die wollten bestimmt Splatoon auch mal pushen.
Das kann schon sein, ja.
Aber es war ein bisschen viel.
Ein bisschen viel Splatoon, ich mein...
Mag ja sein, dass die Musik nicht schlecht ist.
Mein Fall ist die Splatoon-Musik wirklich nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt können wir was anderes machen.
Aber, jede zweite Song, Splatoon, muss ja echt nett sein.
Okay.
Also, wo lädt man jetzt hier irgendwelche Templates runter?
Also, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
Ich find's cool, was man damit alles machen kann.
Aber ich find, die Übersichtlichkeit ist...
...jetzt erstmal nicht direkt da.
Das muss nicht schlecht sein.
Solange man das eine Weile verwendet und sich gut dran gewöhnt, ist alles in Ordnung.
Wohle nicht.
Wo lade ich Templates runter?
Kann man hier oben suchen?
Template.
Ne.
Wo lade ich Templates runter?
Was auf Local und dann Content?
Ach du Scheiße, da hätte ich jetzt ewig gesucht, Chat.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem und dem?
Ach, das hier ist für ISOs und das hier ist für VMs, hä?
Okay.
Template.
Muss ich jetzt auswählen, was ich haben will?
Gibt's dann Alpina?
Gibt's dann Alpin oder sowas?
Alp...ja, perfekt.
Okay, man kann auch nur eins downloaden.
Ja, die Ausgabe könnte auch ein bisschen schöner sein, aber da will ich mich jetzt mal nicht drüber beschweren.
Task finished.
Okay.
Templates.
Alpin haben wir.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch eh schon ein neues Ubuntu.
Einfach weil's geht.
Chat, hat irgendeiner von euch das hauptsächlich im Einsatz bei euch?
Nutzt du Cudi aktiv?
Ist es möglich, in Cudi 2 Reverse-Proxys zu haben?
Klar.
Achso, geht noch weiter.
Einmal einer, der nur auf API reagiert und der andere soll andere anfragen.
Ja, klar, das geht.
Also Cudi 2 hab ich nicht.
Das liegt aber daran, dass das schon eine Weile läuft.
Aber mit Cudi 1 geht das.
Also sind das jetzt unprivilegierte LXC-Container.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie der das startet.
C2HO sagt, ich hatte Proxmox laufen, hatte aber alle 14 Tage einen Crash und alles ist
weggeflogen.
Okay.
Aber die meisten im Chat sind zufrieden.
Kann Proxmox keine Docker-Container starten?
Nicht direkt.
Das ist genau das, was ich jetzt ausprobieren will.
Nämlich angeblich kann man mittlerweile einen Proxmox-Container starten und in dem
Docker starten.
Was vollkommen okay ist, weil Container in Container ist quasi kein Unterschied zu Container
in Host starten.
Also das ist nicht so wie Nested-Virtualisierung, wo es wirklich Leistung frisst.
Bei Container macht es eigentlich keinen Unterschied, ob ich Container in Container
in Container starte.
Weil, ich habe es ja schon oft genug gesagt, Linux-Container im Prinzip gar keine Container.
Das Container ist so ein scheiß Wort dafür.
Es ist eigentlich nur ein weiterer Prozess mit ein bisschen Sandbox drum herum.
Also ob du jetzt den Prozess auf dem Host direkt startest oder in einem Container, macht
eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Außer, dass der Container selbst ein bisschen mehr Sandbox drum herum hat.
Es sagen zwar alle ja, man kann Container nicht mit VMs vergleichen, aber machen es
dann doch irgendwie.
Und deswegen finde ich das Wort Container nicht so richtig passend.
Ich weiß nicht, ganz ehrlich, vielleicht hätte man es besser Sandbox nennen sollen.
Wann machen wir eigentlich mal einen Stream mit Serverless Computing?
Wieso?
Machen wir doch ganz oft.
Ich lasse das Zeug einfach auf meinem Desktop laufen.
Es ist schwierig.
Linux-mäßig oder sonst was, Serverless zu zeigen.
Was wir machen können ist, wir können mal irgendwelche Firebase oder irgendwie sowas
verwenden.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie spannend das ist.
In der Virtualisierung spricht man eigentlich auch nicht von Containern.
Ja, das wollte ich damit, das habe ich auch so nicht gemeint.
Es gibt bei allen Guides, steht es halt drinnen, so nach dem Motto, Container sind keine VMs.
Aber dann werden Container trotzdem wieder so beschrieben wie VMs.
Was ja eigentlich keinen Sinn ergibt, weil ein Container ist kein eigenes System an sich.
Es ist ein stinknormaler weiterer Prozess auf deinem Host-System, wie jeder andere Prozess auch.
Nur, dass noch ein bisschen Sandbox-Kram drum herum ist.
Oder dazwischen ist oder sonst was.
Deswegen kannst du ja in Containern beispielsweise auch, du kannst, deswegen kannst du ja auch in Container A nicht Kernel-Modul sowieso verwenden.
Und in Container B quasi ein anderes Kernel-Modul mit einer anderen, das geht nicht.
Das ist alles ein Prozess unter dem gleichen Host.
Okay, also wie legen wir denn jetzt den hier mal Containers an?
Was machen jetzt die Ubuntu-Installationen?
Die ist am installieren.
Create Container.
Okay, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Hostname.
Omega 0.
Next.
Template.
Ubuntu. So, dann müssen wir mal, Docker PXE.
Oh Gott.
Okay, Firefox. Alles klar. Restarte.
Übrigens, der Firefox backt dann auch immer ganz gerne rum.
Und startet sich nicht neu, obwohl er sagt Restarting.
Denn sie badet so richtig.
Ich habe aber das Gefühl, ich sollte mal meine VM neu starten.
Soll ich denn da noch alles nachinstallieren?
Okay, ne, ich starte jetzt die VM nicht neu.
Da hat sich sogar die Anmeldung gemerkt.
So, Docker Proxmox.
Hier.
Proxmox mit Docker im LXC-Container.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Also, mit der aktuellen Proxmox-Version lässt sich Docker auch in einem LXC-Container betreiben.
Was natürlich viel besser ist als in einer VM.
Weil man dann nicht sinnloserweise nochmal eine Virtualisierungssache dazwischen hat, die man gar nicht braucht.
Damit dies funktioniert, sind aber...
Okay, der neue Container muss unprivileged sein.
Mittlerweile Standard.
Hier müssen keyctl und nesting aktiviert sein.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt machen.
Sonst funktioniert das Ganze nämlich nicht.
Also.
Neuer Container.
Dockzor.
Passwort 123456. 123456.
Unprivileged haben wir hier drin. Sehr gut. Template.
Äh, ist es irgendwie wichtig, was man für ein Template nimmt?
Weil wenn nicht, nehmen wir irgendein Alp...
Komm, wir nehmen mal...
Wir nehmen mal das...
...Ploated-Template.
Da ist auf jeden Fall alles dabei.
Root-Disk.
8G. Ja, wunderbar. Reicht.
Ein Core-Memory reicht auch.
Network. Wunderbar.
Ach, Advanced. Ich dachte, das muss man nachher mal installieren machen.
Confirm.
Äh, wo stellt man den ganzen anderen Kram ein?
Das stellt man erst nach dem Anlegen an, oder?
Finish.
Da ist er.
Create.
Was macht der denn jetzt?
What the fuck?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, was er...
Ich glaube, er hat das Iso... das Image extrahiert oder sowas.
So, und jetzt gehen wir in die Settings und stellen was ein?
Options, Features.
Options.
Features.
Nesting und das da. Okay.
Alles klar.
Ähm.
Docker lässt sich jetzt problemlos in einem LXC-Container installieren.
Ausführen.
Okay, wenn das alles ist, ist es ja...
Ehrlich gesagt...
Aber gucken wir mal, ob das...
...ist.
Start.
Console.
Postchamp.
Ah.
Äh, ist es root?
Okay, das heißt, die... ähm...
Die Container virtua... also die... sag ich auch schon, virtualisieren.
Die Container-Geschichte bei...
Proxmox ist also eher Richtung LXD.
Also quasi, man virtu... äh, nein.
Man...
Man macht nicht wie bei Docker einen einzelnen Prozess,
sondern man containerisiert sich quasi ein komplettes Betriebssystem-Image
mit Init und allem, was dazugehört.
Also sprich, man kann sich einloggen, hat eine Shell und sonst was.
Docker hat ja ein bisschen... oder Potman oder was auch immer.
Oder auch letztendlich, wenn du deine Sachen in Kubernetes laufen lässt,
da ist ja der Ansatz eher,
man startet nicht...
ein komplettes Init, was ein komplettes System startet,
sondern man startet nur...
das Programm, was man starten will.
Tomtricks!
Zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Excellent subscription.
So, das heißt, ich hab jetzt hier ein ganz normales Ubundo drin.
Okay.
Das ist schlecht.
Und wie...
What the fuck? Und wie komm ich jetzt da nach außen?
Max, altes Haus, wie geht's dir?
Ja, geht so.
Ich schließ mal daraus, du bist schon lange am Start, auch auf YouTube.
Hm.
Doch klar, kannst du...
Init-Sachen... du kannst generell...
Gut.
Die haben, glaube ich, kein vollständiges Init hier laufen.
Die haben irgendwelche Start-Skripte, die da andere Sachen...
Aber guck, es ist mehr oder weniger ein komplettes...
nochmal ein komplett eigenes Ubuntu, was hier läuft.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wie wenn du da...
Change-Route machst.
So, wie...
Was hat der für Schmerzen im Moment?
Route?
Nee, IPRO.
Äh, wie... wie kriege ich dem jetzt gesagt?
Ach, man muss ihm sagen, dass er sich das per DHCP ziehen soll.
Ach so, ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das ist Default.
Okay, Network?
So, ist doch eigentlich...
Edit?
Ach...
Okay.
Das ist aber auch wirklich...
das einzige, was ich kenne, was standardmäßig Static hat...
und man dann leer lassen darf, anstatt dass defaultmäßig DHCP ausgewählt ist.
Das ist ja...
Also...
jetzt nicht gerade intuitiv.
Weil ich mein Ende nicht...
Weil ich mein Ende, da kannst du DHCP machen.
Wozu soll ich Static konfigurieren?
Da könntest du mich zumindest drauf hinweisen.
Achtung, keine IP eingetragen.
Okay, aber gut.
Der Chat...
Der Chat weiß wieder Bescheid.
Chat hat wieder Ahnung.
Ich nicht.
So wie immer.
So, und jetzt starten wir das mal neu.
Und gucken, ob wir jetzt...
ins Internet raus dürfen.
Auf was für einer... ähm...
Distro basiert brauchst du noch Debian?
Ah...
Das sieht doch jetzt schon viel besser aus.
Guck mal, jetzt funktioniert das schon mal gleich viel besser.
So.
Also das ist quasi eher so eine LXD-Virtualisierungsgeschichte.
Äh...
Containerisierungsgeschichte.
Weniger eine Docker-Geschichte.
Aber das ist eigentlich echt ganz gut.
Und jetzt kann ich hier drinnen...
Docker-Gedöns laufen lassen.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir.
Ja, weil ich...
Das letzte Mal war das auch noch so.
Das letzte Mal musste man eine VM anlegen, um darin Docker-Gedöns laufen lassen zu können.
Das ist aber auch schon ein bisschen her, wo ich das ausprobiert hab.
Und...
Das finde...
Das war auch der Grund, warum ich gesagt hab, nee, also es gefällt mir nicht so.
Weil wie gesagt, aktuell hab ich eine Kiste hier stehen.
Ubuntu-Server draufgeklatscht.
Mit dem Debian 10 wär ich...
Könnte ich auch leben, ja.
Ähm...
Und... äh...
Hab da einen Docker-Compose-File.
Und...
6, 7 Dinger laufen und fertig.
Läuft's denn nicht stabil?
Weiß nicht.
Also so viele Leute, wie Proxmox verwenden, würde ich schon sagen, dass das prinzipiell ganz gut läuft.
Ich mag Ubuntu-Server.
Was mir.
Das einzige, was mir auf den Sack geht bei Ubuntu-Server, ist das hier.
Vielleicht hat ja schon einer die Ehre, das hier verwenden zu dürfen.
Irgendjemand bei den Ubuntu-Leuten kam auf die Chlorac-Idee.
Es ist eine gute Idee, dass man seine Netzwerke jetzt in Jammin machen muss.
Richtig häng geblieben, ey.
Also, das finde ich einen total你有 nighttime thing.
Also, das finde ich einen total geniusenл普res fi15.
Das finde ich total, also das finde ich mega hängen geblieben.
Netzwerk-Config in YAML zu machen, das finde ich echt richtig hängen geblieben.
Ansonsten mag ich Ubuntu lieber.
Letztendlich muss man aber auch mal ehrlicherweise sagen,
Ubuntu ist ja so ein halbes Debian.
Also, es ist jetzt nicht so ein Wahnsinnsunterschied.
Aber keiner mag Netplan, das ist ja gerade das Witzige daran.
So, und hier drauf können wir uns jetzt einen Dogger installieren, oder wie ist das?
Okay, wir gucken erstmal, ob man sich da mal per SSH einloggen kann, ob das funktioniert.
Wir haben 2, 1, 3, 6, probieren wir mal.
SSH, 1, 3, 6, muss man das auch als Root machen?
Nein, das muss man nicht als Root machen.
Ne, Root ist wahrscheinlich einfach per SSH deaktiviert.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich in der SSH-Config, weil es ist standardmäßig so,
dass man sich per SSH eigentlich nicht...
...per Root einloggen soll.
Und deswegen haben die wahrscheinlich...
Erstmal den WIM installieren, die wichtigsten Sachen.
Okay, die wichtigsten Sachen sind WIM, HATOP, TMAX.
Die 3 Sachen braucht man immer, da kommt man nicht dran vorbei.
Was ich dann immer noch gerne installiere ist...
...DSTAT für I.O. Auslastung.
What the hell?
Ne, geht doch.
Aber HATOP ist...
Also, TMAX und die 2 Dinger braucht man immer.
Also, ohne kommst du auf ein Linux-System quasi gar nicht...
Also, könnt ich nicht mehr leben.
So, und jetzt müssen wir erstmal die SSH-Config editieren und gucken,
ob Root-Login vielleicht verboten ist.
Hier, Permit Root-Login.
Yes.
System, CTL, Restart, SSH, D.
So, und jetzt darf ich da wahrscheinlich auch per Root drauf.
Zack.
Siehst du?
Wunderbar.
Also...
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also, ich muss sagen, das ist für mich jetzt so ein echt richtiger Pluspunkt,
den jetzt, den sich Porgsbox verdient hat.
So, dass ich das fast einsetzen könnte.
Ich meine, ich werde es wahrscheinlich nicht einsetzen,
weil ich meine Kiste hier mit meinem Ubuntu-Server drauf schon fix und fertig habe
und da eigentlich alles funktioniert.
Dass man jetzt keine VMA braucht, um Docker oder Potman oder sonst was verwenden zu können.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
So, ähm, das heißt, wir haben ab...
Install.
Gucken wir mal.
Das ist ein aktuelles Ubuntu.
Das sollte relativ gut passen.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das alles funktioniert mit Containern.
Containern.
Übrigens, was ein richtig cooles Dashboard ist,
was ich euch bei Gelegenheit auch mal zeigen muss.
Gerade für Leute, die lieber ein kleines Webinterface haben,
als da irgendwie Kommandozeilen-mäßig großartig was zu machen,
ist das hier.
Da kann man die Basic-Sachen auf dem Linux-System recht gut über ein Webinterface erledigen mit.
Weiß gar nicht, ob es das hier gibt.
Wie gesagt, ihr wisst ja, ich bin Kommandozeilen...
Ah, guck mal, der ist sogar da.
Ich bin ja Kommandozeilen-Fan.
Mich freut das, wenn ich das alles machen kann.
Übers Terminal.
So, Docker-PS.
Aha, hängt.
Ne, geht.
Ja, wunderbar.
Okay.
Äh, dann machen wir hier mal zu.
So, jetzt machen wir den...
Den Hallo-Welt-Container.
Testen wir jetzt mal, ob der funktioniert.
Und danach testen wir, ob der Who-Am-I-Container funktioniert,
weil der braucht eine Netzwerkverbindung.
Hello from Docker, okay.
Der Hello-World-Container funktioniert.
Jetzt der nächste Test, funktioniert der Who-Am-I-Container.
Der Who-Am-I-Container ist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger
ein Hello-World-Container, nur, dass man es über einen Browser abrufen kann.
So, kann ich den Kamm runterladen.
Wunderbar.
Was, dass Debian immer noch die Packages von Ubuntu-Servern...
Machen sie?
Ne, machen sie nicht, oder?
Warum sollten sie das machen?
Wär mir jetzt neu.
So, gucken wir mal, welcher Port ist dran.
Port.
3, 2, 7, 6, 8.
Also, 1, 2, 1, 2, 2, 1, 3, 6 war es, glaube, ne?
Zack, funktioniert.
Ja, das ist nice.
So, äh, upinstall docker-compose.
Das ist...
Das finde ich echt nice.
Äh, das ist ja auch ein Ubuntu.
Das ist...
Das ist ein Ubuntu im Proxmox...
Also, Proxmox selbst auf Debian-Basis.
Echt?
Als ich abbenutzt habe auf dem anderen war, war das Ubuntu?
Okay.
Äh, welche Passwortverwaltung nutzt ihr auf der Arbeit?
Wir suchen gerade nach einer sinnvollen Lösung für kleine, mittlere Teams.
Ähm, also wir hatten die ganze Zeit immer Keepers.
Das weiß ich daheim auch ab.
Aber...
Irgendwelche...
Big Brain Stonks-Leute haben sich jetzt überlegt, dass Keepers zu schlecht ist.
Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt das hier verwenden.
Passt mal auf.
Aber das empfehle ich nicht.
Ich will es euch bloß noch sagen.
Jetzt müssen wir das hier verwenden.
Und das ist die schlimmste und hässlichste Windows-Only-Anwendung, die ich je gesehen habe.
Guckt euch das mal an, ey.
Ja.
Ich meine...
Ist das euer Ernst?
Passwort-Safe?
Alter.
Was soll das sein?
Ja, das müssen wir jetzt verwenden.
Und das Geile ist ja...
Das Geile ist ja, dass wir, ähm...
Dass wir letztens so ein Verschlüsselungstrojaner am Start hatten.
Und das hat instant dazu geführt, dass der Passwort-Safe nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Weil das das falsche System verschlüsselt hat.
Aber Keepers hat funktioniert.
Und dann habe ich die Leute gefragt...
Max, hast du das Root-Passwort noch irgendwo?
Da habe ich dann gesagt, nein, natürlich habe ich das Root-Passwort nirgendwo mehr.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin, wenn ich das Root-Passwort irgendwie noch bei mir gespeichert hätte?
Ja, aber ihr habt doch früher Keepers gehabt.
Ist da nicht das Root-Passwort noch irgendwo drinne?
Da bin ich erstmal zu meinem Chef abgesagt.
Und habe ihn gefragt, ähm...
Darf ich denn das Root-Passwort noch wissen?
Da meinte er, ja.
Also...
Jetzt schon.
Normalerweise nicht, aber...
Aber jetzt dürfte ich das Root-Passwort noch wissen.
Ja, und dann wusste ich das Root-Passwort auch noch.
Weil ich das noch im Keepers stehen hatte.
Der natürlich noch funktioniert hat.
Nachdem der Passwort-Safe-V8 nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Das ist eh geil.
Die machen...
Vielleicht kennen das manche auch so...
So aus Super-Business-Enterprise-Stonks-Läden, Firmen.
Die sind da immer super...
Pingelig bei allem.
Aber wenn es mal nicht geht...
Und, ähm...
Auch so nicht geht...
Also so weit nicht geht, dass es auch wirklich Geld verloren geht...
Dann wird auf einmal auf alle Stonksachen geschissen.
Oder dann wird auf einmal auf alles geschissen, was sonst ultra wichtig ist.
Und da frage ich mich dann immer so...
Okay, ich sehe ein, dass gewisse Vorgaben und Abläufe...
Dass das bis zu einem gewissen Grad alles sinnvoll ist.
Ich glaube, das stellt auch keiner...
Irgendwo in Frage.
Ähm...
Aber wenn man dann doch...
Im Ernstfall...
Quasi auf die halblegalen Dinger, die man vorher abschaffen wollte...
Doch zurückgreifen muss...
Weil das eigene System, was man aus...
Bürokratie-Overhead geschafft hat...
Geschafft hat...
Im Ernstfall nicht handlungsfähig ist...
Ähm...
Dann frage ich mich doch...
Warum kommen die Leute nicht auf die Idee, sich zu sagen...
Okay, vielleicht ist das, was wir da aufgebaut haben...
Doch nicht...
Doch nicht so...
Das Beste.
Weil wenn das richtig gut durchdacht wäre alles...
Dann würde man auch einen Plan haben für den Ernstfall.
Und nicht auf so halblegale Dinger, die eigentlich keiner mehr haben kann...
Zurückgreifen müssen.
Dann hätte man ein ordentliches Ausfallkonzept, was das hier auch abfackelt.
Oh, hat man aber nicht.
Gehabt.
So, also.
Dogger.
Habe ich den Dogger Compose jetzt schon installiert?
Ja, habe ich.
Wunderbar.
Ähm...
Wir machen mal...
Wir machen mal einen simplen...
Einen simplen...
Simplen Dogger Compose.
Ein simples Dogger Compose-File.
Who am I?
Example.
Oh, mit Traffic auch noch.
Oh yeah, jetzt wollen wir das jetzt aber echt wissen.
Ich wollte jetzt ja eigentlich kein Traffic mehr davor...
Davor Reverse Load Balancer...
Okay, das können wir aber mal machen.
Weil dann sehen wir wenigstens, ob alles richtig funktioniert.
Machen wir jetzt mal.
Ähm...
Muss man das als Root laufen lassen?
Eher nicht.
Aber ich habe keinen anderen User.
Komm, wir lassen das jetzt mal als Root laufen.
Compose.
So, ähm...
Nur mal zur Erklärung.
Wer das nicht so oft verwendet.
Es gibt...
Wie gesagt, also Dogger, denke ich, ist den meisten mittlerweile im Begriff.
Dogger sind keine Container.
Das muss man...
Das kann man nicht oft genug betonen.
Also, Dogger ist nicht gleich Container.
Dogger ist ein...
Quasi ein...
Ein...
Gui.
Oder ein...
Eine...
Ein Frontend.
Für die Verwaltung von Containern.
Dogger ist nicht gleich Container.
Weil, egal was es ist, ob es Dogger ist, Potman ist,
Kubernetes ist,
äh, Rancher OS ist,
äh, Atomic gab es früher noch,
ähm, Core OS,
ach, was es da nicht alles, äh, für...
für Containermanagement-Geschichten gibt.
Was fällt...
Fällt euch noch was ein?
Gibt...
Gibt noch...
Gibt noch zig...
Zig andere Dinger.
Ja, OpenStack, ach, was auch immer alles.
So.
Und...
Egal, was man davon verwendet.
Unter der Haube...
Ist das alles...
Das Gleiche.
Das ist...
Benutzt alles die gleichen Sachen, die im Linux-Kernel drin sind.
Also sprich, ist es egal, ob ich Dogger, Potman oder Kubernetes verwende.
Unter der Haube...
Verwende ich LXC-Container.
Oder, oder...
Also LX...
LXC nennt sich das Ding, was im Linux-Kernel drin ist.
Es ist ein bisschen doppeldeutig.
Weil LXC auch eine minimale Frontend-Implementierung ist.
Und Ubuntu kam dann irgendwann an und hat aus LXC LXD gemacht.
Um das Ganze...
Noch ein bisschen verwirrender zu machen.
Aber die ganzen Linux-Kernel-Geschichten...
Das ist alles für alle Frontends das Gleiche.
Es gibt...
Eine Implementierung im Linux-Kernel, die sich zusammensetzt aus...
Ähm...
Cgroups und Namespaces.
Das ist so die Hauptsache.
Also Cgroups ist quasi sowas wie...
Ähm...
Ich kann Ressourcenmanagement machen.
Das äh...
Prozess XY...
Darf nicht mehr verwenden als 200 RAM und einen CPU-Kern und sowas.
Das ist Cgroups.
Und was Docker-Compose ist, da komm ich jetzt gleich drauf, nachdem ich erklärt hab, was das ganze Container-Gedöns eigentlich ist, noch mal im schnellen Verfahren.
Ähm...
So, das ist einmal Cgroups.
Das ist für so...
Ressourcen-Management zuständig.
Und dann gibt's Namespaces.
Das ist dafür da, dass ähm...
Man quasi dem Container vorgaukeln kann, dass Sachen anders sind.
Zum Beispiel, dass ein Container Verzeichnisse sieht, die es auf dem Host gar nicht gibt.
So, und...
Oder, oder, dass man äh...
Netzwerksachen anlegen kann und der Container denkt, das wäre das einzige Netzwerk, was es gibt und sowas in der Richtung.
Also die zwei Sachen.
Es gibt Cgroups und Namespaces.
Das ist das, woraus sich Container zusammensetzen.
Und ein Linux-Container ist nix anderes, wie ein stinknormaler Prozess mit quasi Cgroups und Namespaces dazu.
Dementsprechend braucht es auch so gut wie kein...
Es braucht eigentlich keine zusätzlichen Ressourcen.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Prozess im Linux-Coil, wie alles andere.
Und ähm...
Diese Sachen...
Egal, ob es Docker, Podman, Kubernetes ist...
Das ist das, was man verwendet.
Wenn man jetzt C, C++...
Man kann das bestimmt mit C-Sharp und Go mittlerweile auch machen.
Man könnte sich...
Ich sag jetzt mal in Anführungsstrichen, ohne Probleme...
Ähm, über die Kernel-APIs...
Einen eigenen Container starten.
Das ist kein Ding. Das kann man machen.
Wenn man kann.
Aber nachdem nicht jeder äh...
Programmierer ist und sich mit Linux-Curdle-Schnittstellen auskennt, hat sich das Ganze so richtig erst durchgesetzt,
als Docker dahergekommen ist und ein einfach zu verwendendes Frontend gebastelt hat für diese ganze Container-Geschichte.
Also Docker, es ist kein Container, Docker ist ein Frontend dafür.
Natürlich macht Docker auch noch ein bisschen mehr, das hat, glaube ich, der Kelmore im Chat ja auch noch gesagt.
Natürlich macht Docker noch ein bisschen mehr, neben dem, dass das Container erstellen kann,
das gibt noch eine Registry, wo du Images runterladen kannst, die haben hier Docker-File-Format,
wie man Images anlegt, wie man Snapshots macht, das ist ein bisschen mehr noch drumherum gebastelt.
Aber im Kern ist Docker ein Frontend für diese C-Groups, Namespaces-Geschichte im Kernel.
Genau, Overlay-FS für File-Systeme, das macht im Detail noch viel, viel mehr.
Aber unter der Haube ist das keine Magic im Endeffekt.
Und alle Container-Frontends, das ist, worauf ich raus will, alle Container-Frontends,
ob Kubernetes, Potman, Docker, Rancher, CoreOS, sonst was,
die verwenden alle unter der Haube die gleichen Schnittstellen im Kernel.
So, und irgendwann ist man auf die Idee gekommen, dass Docker an sich ja eine coole Sache ist,
aber es wäre praktisch, wenn man die Systeme,
wenn man mehrere Systeme reproduzierbar aufbauen könnte oder neu erstellen könnte.
Und dann, da kommt Docker-Compose ins Spiel.
Es gibt viele Überschneidungen.
Also sprich, das, was Kubernetes macht, ist ja im Prinzip die,
neben dem, was Docker macht mit Container-Anlegen,
Kubernetes ist hauptsächlich dazu da, einen gewissen definierten Zustand zu halten.
Also sprich, man sagt zum Beispiel, dieser Service muss auf drei verschiedene Hosts laufen
oder, keine Ahnung, wenn auf dem Load-Balancer so und so viel Last ist,
dann mehr Container starten oder irgendwelche Geschichten.
Also Kubernetes ist dafür da, diese ganze Container-Geschichte,
so wie man so schön sagt, zu orchestrieren.
Weniger jetzt als reines Container starten, stoppen, anlegen, Frontend.
Und nachdem Kubernetes ein ganz schön fettes Ding,
und es eigentlich total overkill ist, da im privaten Bereich auf einem Rechner was zu machen,
gibt es da ein bisschen leichtgewichtige Varianten.
Und das Einfachste, was man machen kann, um seine Container reproduzierbar aufzubauen
und zu versionieren, ist Docker-Compose.
Also sprich, anstatt, dass man jeden Docker-Container von Hand startet und stoppt
und Parameter angibt, was man für Ordner verwenden,
was man für Ports verwenden will, schreibt man das alles in YAML-File
und dann sagt man Docker-Compose ab und der applied quasi alles das,
was in diesem YAML-File drin steht.
Das einfachste Docker-Compose-File sieht zum Beispiel so aus.
Wobei, wir machen das jetzt mal hiermit.
So, Docker-Compose.yaml, set-paste, zack.
So, was das jetzt macht ist, also wir gucken jetzt mal an, was das macht
und was ich dafür vorstelle.
Was ich davon handmachen müsste.
Das erstellt zwei Container und zwar einmal einen Container mit dem Namen traffic
und einmal einen Container mit dem Namen whoami.
So, und was ist da drinne?
Hier startet er das Image, dieses Image, das muss halt irgendwo bereitgestellt werden
und hier startet er dieses Image.
In dem Fall ist es so, das hier ist quasi eine Reverse-Proxy, HTTP,
Load-Palancer, Verschnitt und das hier ist der eigentliche Service.
Das könnte ich alles von Hand starten, aber so ist es einfacher.
Zumal der Vorteil davon ist, das Docker-Compose-File kann ich ins Git einchecken,
irgendwo pushen und auf einer anderen Kiste auschecken und dann gehe ich einfach da rein,
Docker-Compose ab.
So, minus D, aber wir gucken jetzt zu.
Und dann legt er alles so an, wie es in diesem Compose-File...
Wo ordnet sich Swarm ein?
Dazwischen.
Ich habe Swarm aber nie verwendet.
Wollte ich dazu sagen.
Dazwischen.
Swarm hat wohl noch ein bisschen mehr Cluster-Management dabei.
Ich meine, Docker-Compose ist ja auch komplett lokal.
Weiß ich, weiß.
Weiß ich, ob man damit auch irgendwas Stream-Mod machen kann, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Swarm ist noch ein bisschen Cluster-Management dabei, aber Swarm ist tot mittlerweile.
Also das wird wohl nicht mehr weiterentwickelt und alles hat sich auf Kubernetes eingeschossen.
So, guck, das war es jetzt.
Also sprich, was der jetzt gemacht hat, ist, der hat jetzt diese zwei Container gestartet
und jetzt kann...
Kann ich auf diesen Server draufgehen, IP wissen wir noch, 10.2.1.3.6.
Zack, und Page not found, weil ich die falsche Domain angegeben habe.
Okay, das war mein Fail, ja.
Das funktioniert ohne DNS natürlich nicht richtig.
Weil ich habe ihm gesagt, ich will Domain verwenden, whoami.localhost.
Und whoami.localhost...
Naja, whoami.localhost geht halt von hier aus nicht.
So, was wir aber machen können, ist...
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt Matrix 17.
Upt install Firefox.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Da muss ich nämlich nichts umstellen.
Wir starten jetzt remote mal ein Firefox auf der Kiste.
PauseChamp.
Das ist auch immer was, wo viele Leute erstmal gucken und denken, was, das funktioniert?
Ja, Kubernetes-Setup ist absolut Cancer, ey.
Was ich bei Kubernetes auch fragwürdig finde...
Also, was ich auch...
Was ich bei vielen anderen Projekten auch fragwürdig finde, ist,
wenn die anfangen, schon bekannte Sachen umzubenennen.
So nach dem Motto, das sind jetzt Pods und sowas.
Muss das sein?
Kann man nicht die Dinge einfach so nennen, wie sich die restliche Welt da was darunter vorstellt?
Da gibt es noch mehr Projekte, die sowas gerne machen.
Ich habe letztens, was war denn das?
Ich habe letztens einen Webcast gesehen.
Was war das denn?
Ich kriege es nicht mehr zusammen.
Da haben sie auch alles umgebracht.
Unbenannt.
Ja, Pods sind in...
Der Kelmer hat natürlich recht.
Pods ist in Kubernetes so die kleinste Einheit, die du managen kannst.
Du kannst ja, glaube ich, gar keine Container direkt managen.
Aber ich mag das nicht, wenn manche Projekte anfangen, altbekannte Sachen, dann neue Namen zu geben, dass es fresher klingt irgendwie.
So.
Achso.
Ich bin ja auch blöd, meint...
So.
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Ich habe jetzt einen Firefox gestartet.
Hier.
Ich habe jetzt einen Firefox gestartet, der auf der Remote-Kiste läuft.
Das ist richtig, Trick 17.
Das kann man sich auch mal merken.
Also, Notizblock zücken.
Wie hättest du denn einen Pod genannt?
Keine Ahnung.
Zum Glück muss ich...
Ihr wisst, wie schlecht ich bin mit Namen, was Variablen angeht.
Vielleicht...
Unit oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Pod war jetzt auch ein...
Als auch ein schlechtes Beispiel.
Container-Group vielleicht oder sowas.
Irgendwas, wo man sich halt ein bisschen was darunter vorstellen kann.
Wobei Container-Group trifft es ja auch nicht so richtig.
So.
Also.
Compose.
Up.
Jetzt haben wir einen Firefox auf.
So.
Und wenn man nämlich...
Wenn man sich nämlich per SSH verbindet auf einen Server und sagt SSH-Y,
dann kann man grafische Anwendungen auf dem Server...
über SSH lokal anzeigen lassen.
Geht nur, wenn man einen X-Server laufen hat.
So. Und jetzt kann ich mal ein...
Whoami.localhost.
Und siehe da.
Das geht nicht.
What?
Das liegt...
Okay. Keine Ahnung, warum das nicht geht.
Ähm...
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass das tut.
Vielleicht ist es auch der Firefox.
Moment.
Vielleicht ist es auch einfach der Firefox, der komische Dinge macht.
Wir machen mal einen Curl.
Whoami.localhost.
Ich hätte jetzt erwartet, dass das Beispiel...
Einfach funktioniert von denen.
Und gestartet ist es auch.
Ach so. Moment.
Ich muss das Host-File wahrscheinlich anpassen.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Ich kann ja gar nicht Whoami.localhost machen, weil es die Domain nicht...
Moment. Kein Curl installiert.
Lull.
Man müsste die Host-Datei eintragen.
Ja, das müsste funktionieren.
Okay.
Jetzt sehe.
Host.
Whoami.
So.
Da sind wir.
Jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Guckt.
Firefox.
Whoami.
Local Host.
Zack.
Da ist es.
Ja, in dem Fall ist Traffic natürlich komplett bescheuert.
Aber das war ein Beispiel halt einfach so drinnen.
Für so eine einfache Sache braucht man das nicht.
So, und jetzt ist der Vorteil davon, dass ich diese Datei nehmen könnte.
Einfach auf eine andere Kiste kopieren.
Starten.
Das wird funktionieren.
Und warum das für mich jetzt im Privat, also für mich jetzt besonders praktisch ist.
Ich würde da jetzt ein Git-Repo draus machen.
Und würde dann quasi...
Jetzt machen mit den Änderungen.
Das heißt, ich kann auch nachgucken, wie habe ich mal was gemacht.
Und vor allem, warum habe ich da mal irgendwie was dran geändert?
So, und so sieht das aktuell auf meiner Server, auf meinem Mini 2 HE Kiste, die hier nebenan mir steht, auch so aus.
Ich habe da einfach sieben Services drin definiert.
Und eingestellt, dass Traffic dafür Let's Encrypt, das haben wir übrigens mal im Stream gemacht, Let's Encrypt Zertifikate ausstellt.
Deswegen haben alle meine...
Deswegen haben alle meine lokalen Services halt gültige Zertifikate.
Ja.
Und es ist ganz nützlich, weil man alle Sachen mit Docker Compose direkt managen kann.
Also man kann zum Beispiel sagen, okay, einfach alle Sachen, die da drin stehen, stoppen und starten.
Ja, wenn ihr das stimmt, also wenn man das jetzt rüber kopiert auf einen anderen Server und startet, dann hat man die Daten, die man hier drauf hat, natürlich nicht mit kopiert.
Man würde dort dann neue Container erzeugen.
Was hast du denn im Docker?
Oh, da muss ich immer...
Da muss ich immer in mich gehen.
Was habe ich?
Ich habe einen Doku-Wiki.
Ich habe einen Git-Dings hier, Frontend.
Warte mal.
Ich habe einen Doku-Wiki, einen Git-Frontend.
Ich habe einen Samba-Server.
Ich habe eine Traffic für Let's Encrypt Zertifikate.
Ich habe einen Container, der die anderen updatet.
Ich habe noch einen Nextcloud, den ich aber weg haben will.
Ich habe so einen Fritzbox.
Fritzbox, ähm, CalDAV-Container, äh, nicht CalDAV, äh, äh, CardDAV-Kontakte zu Fritzbox und Fritzphone-Converter.
Ähm, was habe ich da noch alles drauflaufen?
Fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein.
Ein paar...
Zwei, drei Sachen sind es noch.
Es ist jetzt nicht so viel.
Ich kann jetzt leider nicht reingucken, weil da stehen auch sicher ein paar Sachen drin, die ich nicht leaken will.
Wie war das mit dem SSH und GUI?
Kannst du das nochmal kurz zeigen?
Ja, klar, kann ich machen.
Also.
Wenn du dich auf eine Kiste verbindest per SSH, das da hinten lassen wir jetzt mal weg.
Ähm, da musst du einfach...
Die alte Variante war minus X, mittlerweile ist es minus Y.
Hast du einen lokalen Git-Server?
Ja, habe ich.
So, du machst SSH minus Y.
Das sorgt dafür, dass wenn du dich einloggst, also der teilt an dem SSH-Server mit,
dass du, äh, X-Forwarding machen willst.
Also das ist das, das ist das, ähm, der Parameter für X-Forwarding.
So, dann sagst du dem Server, hallo, ich möchte X-Forwarding machen.
Das setzt natürlich voraus, äh, doch, minus X geht noch, aber es war irgendein Unterschied zwischen minus X und minus Y.
Wir können mal kurz gucken, was der Unterschied ist.
Okay, also der Unterschied ist...
Enable 6 Forwarding.
So, und was ist minus Y?
Okay.
Das ist der Unterschied, frag mich nicht.
Da muss man wahrscheinlich irgendwelche anderen Sachen...
Keine Ahnung.
Es, früher hat man immer minus X verwendet, mittlerweile...
Eigentlich nur minus Y.
Max spiegelt sich in der SSD ja schon die ganze Zeit.
Scheiße.
Jetzt seh ich's ja jetzt erst.
Ich spiegel mich in der SSD.
Doch, minus X geht noch.
Also, äh, du machst minus Y, damit teilst du dem SSH-Server mit, hallo, ich möchte X-Forwarding machen.
Dann loggst du dich ganz normal ein.
Und wenn du dich das erste Mal einloggst, erstellt der sowas hier.
Ich kann das mal kurz löschen, dass du siehst, wie das ausschaut.
Wenn du dich dann das erste Mal einloggst...
Dann legt er so nen, ähm, X-Authority-File an.
Das ist irgendwie dafür da, dass einer deine Session nicht hijacken kann, frag mich nicht.
Ich weiß es im Detail nicht.
Und wenn du das siehst, weißt du schon mal, aha, hat alles funktioniert.
Und dann kannst du einfach eine grafische Anwendung starten über SSH.
Man muss aber sagen, das ist langsam, ne, wie du hier siehst.
Also, Geschwindigkeitsrekorde gewinnst du mit einer grafischen Anwendung über SSH nicht.
Ach ja, und der Fips hat recht.
Das ist langsam.
Das muss aktiviert sein.
Also, wenn der SSH-Server kein X-Forwarding erlaubt, geht das nicht.
Aber mir ist kein Betriebssystem, was mir jetzt so einfällt, was standardmäßig X-Forwarding deaktiviert hätte.
Vielleicht CoS oder sowas.
Du könntest in Samba 4 Domain-Controller bestimmt als Docker-Container starten.
Jaja, garantiert.
Aber da weiß ich nicht wie, weil die Samba-Config ist ätzend.
Also, na, wir können jetzt mal hier, äh, WebGL testen.
Test machen.
Da sehen wir mal, wie lahm das Ganze ist.
Guck mal, ihr seht schon, wie lahm die Seite, wie lahm die Seite lädt, ne.
Also, also schnell ist das wirklich nicht.
Wir können mal meinen Twitch-Stream anmachen.
Guck mal hier.
SSH, SSH, X-Forwarding, Firefox.
Sieht halt schon ein bisschen kaputt aus, ne.
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
HPN, SSH.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass es an das aktuelle RDP rankommen wird mit 3D.
Beschleunigungsgedöns und sowas.
Also, das ist halt der Witz, ne.
So, wir können, ihr seht schon, guck mal hier, neuer Tab hier.
Alter, wie es ruckelt.
Mal Twitch, Woblords aufmachen.
Ihr seht schon, was das für ein Input-Lag hat.
Arch hat es standardmäßig aus.
Okay, das, das, das wird mir sogar einleuchten, weil die haben ja standardmäßig auch nicht mal einen SSH-Server laufen, ne.
Also, sie mussten auch von Hand einschalten und sowas.
Die sagen halt, sie sind Desktop.
Gibt es jemanden, der Arch, Linux oder Gentoo auf dem Server verwendet von euch?
Mag ja so ein paar Hardcore-Leute geben, aber ich glaube, das ist verschwindend gering.
Stellt euch mal vor, müsst irgendwie was, irgendwie Libraries in der ersten Runde kompilieren, ne.
Ja, also guckt mal hier, das ist wirklich, also schnell, schnell ist was anderes, ne.
Schnell ist was anderes.
Aber es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Zum Ausprobieren ist das gut.
Und wisst ihr, wofür wir das, oder wofür ich das auf der Arbeit lange verwendet habe?
Äh, Remote SSH.
Ja, ähm, Browser.
Wir hatten mal eine Kiste, da war ein, ich glaube sogar ein Oracle-Linux-Vollinstallation drauf.
Das musste, das musste eine Oracle-Linux-Vollinstallation sein, weil das das Einzige war, was irgendwo vom Hersteller supported war, fragt mich nicht.
Und, ähm, da lief ein Service drauf, das war irgendein Dokumentenmanagement-System.
Und das hatte ein Admin-Interface.
Und dieses Admin, also natürlich, natürlich.
Wir reden...
Wir reden ja hier vom Business-Enterprise-Stonks-Umfeld.
Da sind die Sachen nicht so einfach, wie man sich das immer so vorstellt.
Die Version, die haben wir mal gekauft und danach haben wir keine Updates mehr gekauft.
Das heißt, wir hatten ein Dokumentenmanagement-System, was seit fünf Jahren nicht mehr supported war und was auch niemand wieder neu aufbauen konnte.
So.
Und das Dokumentenmanagement-System hatte halt ein Admin-Interface.
Und das Admin-Interface, das wollte man halt dadurch, dass es eben so ein uralt unsupportedes Sonstwas-Ding ist.
Nicht einfach ins Netzwerk stellen.
Deswegen haben wir gesagt, okay, Zugriff auf das Admin-Interface nur von Localhost und haben es komplett überall gesperrt.
Und Zugriff auf das Admin-Interface haben wir dann gemacht per SSH.
Äh, per Browser über SSH.
Es gibt noch andere Varianten, man könnte auch Port-Weiterleitung über SSH machen.
Aber das war eine Weile.
Ich mein, besser als Lynx oder irgendwie so komisches Zeug verwenden.
Wenn so etwas abbraucht, ist man richtig am Sack, ja.
Wir haben aktuell auch was.
Das ist ein Seminar.
Das ist ein Seminarbuchungssystem.
Ja, sowas, sowas.
Also sprich, dort können sich Außendienstleute anmelden, um Seminare zu buchen.
Dann kriegen sie dann erzählt hier die tollen neuen, was weiß ich, Versicherungsprodukte, die ihr verkaufen könnt und sowas.
So.
Und dieses System haben wir gekauft.
Das ist so eine richtige Stonks-Story jetzt.
Wo wirklich wieder die absoluten Spezialisten am Start waren.
Also, man hat sich das gekauft damals.
Hat aber gesagt, noch weniger.
Noch quasi bevor man es gekauft hat, dass es eigentlich nicht genau das ist, also nicht so das System ist, was man haben will, was eigentlich schon wieder ein bisschen merkwürdig ist.
Warum kauft man es dann?
Wahrscheinlich gehört die Firma irgendwie einem Neffe von einem oder so.
Weiß nicht.
So.
Und zumindest man hat das System gekauft und hat quasi schon im gleichen Atemzug gesagt, na ja, gut, aber so wirklich das, was wir brauchen, ist es nicht.
Aber dann hat die, die, die, der Hersteller hat natürlich Geld gewittert und hat gesagt Aha, kein Problem.
Wir passen es euch an.
So, also haben wir unser Seminarbuchungssystem gekauft.
Quasi mit einem Entwicklungsvertrag mit dem Softwarehersteller, dass der das so umwurstet für uns, dass das uns gefällt.
So, und dann haben sie festgestellt, als das fertig war und es installiert war auf den auf den Servern, haben sie festgestellt.
Oh, Scheiße.
Pass mal auf, das ist kein Witz.
Das Ding basiert ja noch auf ColdFusion.
Weiß nicht, ob das noch jemand kennt.
Das ist doch ColdFusion.
So.
Und dann kam das, da kam das nächste Problem.
ColdFusion ist ja komplett, äh, ja, verwendet kein Mensch mehr.
Und, ähm, ja, das braucht irgendwie eine Java-Runtime oder so, ne?
Das braucht, nee, das braucht einen JBoss.
Das braucht einen JBoss.
Das braucht einen JBoss auf Java-Basis, dass es läuft.
Ich versuch das gerade aus dem Kopf zu rekonstruieren.
Ähm, und das Problem war dann, dass die, diese Version, die die verwendet haben, nur mit einem alten JBoss lief, der allerdings so alt war, dass die, das Red Hat, das Java, was im Repo war, zu neu gewesen ist.
So, so, genau.
Also sprich, wir konnten das Ding, obwohl es neu gekauft war, nicht supported auf unseren Systemen betreiben.
Also richtig, eine richtig absolute Big-Brain-Entscheidung war das Ganze.
So.
Und jetzt, um die Brücke, um die Brücke zum Thema Container zu schlagen, ähm, der Kellner hat's schon erraten, der hat's schon erraten.
Um jetzt die Brücke zu Container zu schlagen, wir haben uns damit ein, zwei Jahre rumgequält.
Ähm, und haben gesagt, hey, wir können das System nicht supporten.
Wir können das System noch nicht mal wieder aufbauen.
Wenn das System Schrott ist, dann ist es Schrott.
Wir können das nicht wieder aufbauen.
So, und da, da sagen natürlich alle immer, ja, ja, kein Problem, das passt schon.
Außer, wenn dann die Kacke am Dampfen ist, dann passt es auf einmal doch nicht mehr.
Und jetzt haben wir es so gemacht, wir haben das System einfach in einen Container gepackt.
Also sprich, wir haben jetzt den gleichen Server wie vorher, gleicher Name, gleicher alles.
Nur, dass dort drauf nochmal ein Docker läuft, wo jetzt diese Anwendung drin containerisiert läuft.
Voll die Brust, durch die Brust ins Auge, ey.
Und manchmal gibt es Probleme, weil, äh, der Hersteller doch ab, also, wir haben ja noch einen Support-Vertrag mit dem Hersteller.
Der Hersteller liefert ab und zu nochmal irgendwelche Updates.
Und dann, dann geht der Restart manchmal nicht und so ganz merkwürdige Dinge.
Also, das Geile ist, Leute von euch, die wahrscheinlich so im Business-Stonks-Enterprise-Umfeld arbeiten, die kennen das.
Solche Software gibt es, sammelt sich mit den Jahren immer mehr an.
Und irgendwann hast du wirklich einen ganzen Zoo von so einem Geschiss.
Und keiner traut sich mehr, jemals was abzuschalten, weil alle Schiss haben.
Irgendjemand, der wichtig ist und Kontakte zum Vorstand hat, braucht das System.
Da hast du dann Dinger, die kosten dich Zehntausende, wenn nicht Hunderttausende Euro.
verwenden noch zwei leute für sachen die noch nicht mal wichtig sind
seine q das ist alles erfahrungssache das kommen wir derzeit ich bin gar nicht
so big brain wie es aussieht gleich wenn man das erste mal hier vorbeikommt
exposed außerdem dass ihr wisst ja das wichtigste was man braucht um big brain
zu werden also neben einem sub auf twitch das ist
natürlich das allerwichtigste ist man braucht ein gutes klo ohne gutes klo
geht nichts weil wie viele sachen einem alles auf dem klo einfallen wo man den
ganzen tag dran sitzt und dann sitzt man auf dem ton sagt so geht das also also
klo investition lohnt sich so wir sind jetzt ein bisschen weit vom thema
abgekommen wir waren ein spiel bei proxmox also das mit docker zeug hat
wunderbar funktioniert
also das mit docker zeug hat wunderbar funktioniert
Was macht eigentlich unsere Ubuntu-VM?
Ist die mittlerweile fertig installiert?
Wir müssen nämlich noch Pass-Thru testen mit der VM.
Der Sirius Max hat eine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Er sagt nämlich, bei mir in der Wohnung wird es irgendwie nicht richtig warm.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Heizung kaputt ist.
Kannst du mir ein Tool empfehlen, um meine Heizung zu tracken?
Zufälligerweise habe ich da was gebaut, um die Heizung zu tracken.
Und zwar kann ich euch das Ganze mal zeigen.
Nein, kommt scheiß drauf.
Irgendwann ist es auch mal ausgelutscht.
Irgendwann ist es auch mal gut.
So ein paar Mal pro Stream kann man den Gag ja machen.
Aber irgendwann ist es ja mal gut.
Verwendest du die Proxima-Kiste dann auch ein bisschen weiter?
Ich werde es mir wahrscheinlich morgen noch ein bisschen off-stream angucken.
So die Feinheiten.
Aber die Kiste da hier oben rechts, wo das drauf läuft.
Die da.
Also, da drauf kannst du ja nichts ernsthaft machen.
Ich meine, das ist ein Low-End-2-Core-Kack-Ding.
Da geht ja gar nichts drauf.
So, Moment.
Was habe ich gesagt, wollte ich jetzt mal machen?
Ach, ob man PC-Karten durchreichen kann.
Genau.
So, was macht denn die Ubuntu vor allem?
Die sagt...
Oh, fuck.
Ich habe den Installer verpennt.
Jetzt muss die ja noch installieren.
Na gut, dann können wir jetzt die Netzwerkkarte einbauen, würde ich sagen.
In der Zwischenzeit.
Ob das...
Ähm, Leute, sollen wir mutig sein und die PCI-Karte in das Board reinstecken,
während es in Betrieb ist und gucken, was passiert?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
So, nächste Frage, Chat.
Chat, nächste Frage.
Ähm, welchen PCI-Slot verwenden wir?
Den Adapter auf M2?
Oder den richtigen PCI-Slot?
Den da?
Oder den da?
Ich bin für den hier.
Ich bin für den hier, weil...
Dann sind die Chancen, wenn es irgendwie abfackelt, größer, dass das Board überlebt.
Dann geht nur der Adapter kaputt.
Okay, äh, wir installieren den Basic-Ubuntu-Server mit OpenSSR.
Continue.
Okay.
Ähm, probieren wir mal aus.
Ich mache mal Fullscreen, dass ihr der ganzen Sache beiwohnen könnt, wenn es jetzt abkackt.
Warum sollte nur der Adapter kaputt gehen?
Naja, wenn man es über den Adapter macht, sind zumindest die Chancen da, dass nur der Adapter kaputt geht.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn es kaputt geht, geht wahrscheinlich alles kaputt.
So, probieren wir mal aus.
Exzellent.
Ja, 10G-Karte.
Ich habe das Slot-Play schon abgemacht, weil sonst würde es da nicht drauf passen.
Oh je.
Oh, Leute.
Geht nicht.
Geht nicht, das passt nicht.
Doch hier unten rein machen.
Passt nicht.
Ich reife schon das Essen an.
Läuft es noch?
Okay.
Äh.
Ich glaube, es ist abgekackt.
Oh, es ist abgekackt.
Leute, die Kiste läuft nicht mehr.
Grip.
Hot-Swap failed.
Aber es ist kein Problem, wir schalten aus und schalten wieder ein.
Das ist alles kein Ding.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es funktioniert.
Ich mache mal kurz die, ähm.
He doesn't know.
He lacks critical information.
Aber guckt mal.
Da blinkt es noch.
Seht ihr?
Der Cursor blinkt noch.
Also das System ist nicht abgekackt.
Kann das sein, dass der durcheinander gekommen ist, weil das eine zweite Netzwerkkarte ist?
Dass der jetzt nicht weiß, welche Netzwerkkarte er anmachen soll?
Okay.
Ich mache mal aus und wieder an.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Schauen wir mal.
Check mal die IP.
Ja, da muss ich die Tastatur umstecken.
Das klappt nicht so einfach.
Aber mal gucken, ob er startet.
Ultra Durable.
Okay, kaputt ist er schon mal.
Nett.
Gut, er meckert jetzt ein bisschen rum, weil ich im laufenden Betrieb ausgeschaltet habe.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Das darf er machen.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal, ob der jetzt wieder da ist.
Da ist er wieder.
Okay, das scheint, das scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Ähm, da ist er wieder.
Er pinkt auch wieder.
Das da oben können wir zumachen.
Das wird nicht mehr gehen.
Ähm.
So, mal gucken, ob er das jetzt erkannt hat, die Netzwerkkarte.
Äh, Port 1.
Ne.
Ja, guck mal.
Zweite Netzwerkkarte erkannt.
Ne, Moment.
Doch.
Zweite Netzwerkkarte erkannt.
Sehr gut.
Ähm.
Ja, dann gucken wir mal, ob jetzt das Durchreichen in die VM funktioniert.
Oh, ne.
Ne.
Die Ubuntu.
Ich hätte die Ubuntu-Installation durchlaufen lassen sollen.
Weil, jetzt ist ja die Installation mittendrin abgekackt.
Boah.
Booting vom Harddrive.
RIP.
Aber die Installation dauert nicht lang.
Das dauert 10 Minuten oder so, wenn es hochkommt.
Ähm.
Wenn man denn dabei bleibt.
Wie sagt man denn, das ist...
Okay, da können wir das nächste Problem uns hier gleich mal...
Alter, geh mal fort mit der Konsole.
Da können wir uns das nächste Problem gleich angucken.
Äh.
Shutdown.
Wie macht man Boot-Reihenfolge?
Hier, Boot-Order.
Network.
Ja.
Warum ist People Love im Stream-Chat-Fenster?
Keine Ahnung.
Äh.
Was will der von mir?
Hallo, ich will ausschalten.
Stopp.
Hallo, ich will die VM ausschalten.
Warum kann ich die VM nicht ausschalten?
Stopp.
Äh.
Wie kriege ich denn eine VM ausgeschaltet?
Ja, irgendwie forcen.
Ja, okay, aber das muss er...
Das muss doch übers Web-Interface gehen, ausschalten.
Was auf Monitor links klicken und dann als Quit.
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Da gibt's kein...
Can't log file.
Jetzt ist es aus.
Warum gibt's da kein Button, was das macht?
Also, ich erwarte mal zumindest, dass man Force ausmachen kann.
Klar, dass der normale Shutdown nicht funktioniert, ist klar.
Ich kann nichts installieren, da ist kein System drauf.
So, hat er jetzt die Boot-Reihenfolge umgestellt?
Boot-Order.
Network.
Gut.
Jetzt können wir auch Start machen wieder.
Console.
Abgestürzt-Damage.
Aber das war nicht abgestürzt, das hing im Boot.
Und ist Boot gleich, er ist abgestürzt, sorry.
Weil das kannst du in so ziemlich jeder anderen Virtualisierungslösung, hast du halt so
einen Force-Stop-Knopf.
Hast du ja hier auch, ne?
Kann ich auch sagen hier, ähm, Power-Off.
Das ist ja quasi Force-Stop.
So, Off.
So.
Linux-Network.
Linux-Network-Installs.
Eine Runde.
Hallo?
Linux-Network-Installs.
Und so.
Jawoll.
Install.
Power-Off ist bei VMware-Stecker raus.
Ja, aber genau sowas will ich ja.
Wenn er hängt, Power-Off.
Bam.
Hast du eine Software-Verteilung?
Ne, ich hab nur einen PXE-Server.
Ich hab den hier, ähm, äh, Netboot.
Den da.
Dazu musst du im Prinzip einfach nur diesen Container starten.
Und in deinem DHCP den Server einladen.
So.
Und in deinem DHCP den Server als Bootserver angeben.
Das wars.
Also du startest einfach nur den Container und die IP von dem Container Host gibst du
in deinem DHCP als Next-Server an.
Das wars.
Mehr musst du nicht machen.
Das ist, das ist wirklich easy.
Easy as a- ... Ja wie gesagt, über Konsole hab ich jetzt ja
ja gerade erfahren, dass es funktioniert.
Aber ich find's merkwürdig, dass, dass da kein Knopf절 gibt.
So jetzt machen wir das Ganze mal hier im Schnelldurchgang.
Okay ó-.
face reveal wenn ich mich das nächste mal in der ssd spiegel test vm wir sind in turks and
caicos island oder sind wir in trinidad and tobago ich kann mich nicht ganz entscheiden
hier turkmenistan alles klar und jetzt habe ich den mirror aus turkmenistan ich glaube das ist
keine so gute idee ich glaube den mirror aus turkmenistan will ich nicht wir sind wir sind
zu null zu null könnten wir sein wir nehmen irgendwas würde mir auch schnelles germany kommt
gut der ist schnell vertraut mir ganz bestimmt ist sehr schnell wie so oder läuft aber die auf
raspberry pi irgendwo am dsl 10 93 950 74 286 exquisite name fragt im chat benutzt du in deiner
und
linux vm auch die multi monitor funktionen bei mir flackert auf dem zweiten monitor der
mauszeiger nein verwende ich nicht ich habe zwei rechner mit zwei monitoren ich habe keine ich
also ich habe die monitore zwar unterschiedlich verbunden mit den rechner also ich könnte
theoretisch jeden monitor von jedem rechner verwenden aber ich mache es meist oder linke
monitor ist an dem einen rechner der rechner monitor ist über einem anderen rechner also
ich verwende eigentlich so gut wie nie dual hat oder wie das heißt und vor allem auch gar nicht
kann ich dir nichts zu sagen auf der arbeit ist es so da haben wir so einen 4k curve widescreen und
wenn ich deine vm in fullscreen habe geht es halt auch weil es sind keine zwei unterschiedliche
monitore hast du dann zwei mal ich habe sogar drei mäuse hier gerade nebeneinander stehen aber nee
ich kann mit der maus von hier rüber auf den anderen bildschirm fahren das mache ich hiermit
maus
maus without borders nennen sich das warum kein kvm na weil es viel besser ist wenn ich hier rüber
kann mit der maus als dass ich das umschalten muss das war früher synergy heute gibt's barrier
use entire disk ja das haben die umbenannt das kann man auch gut verwenden aber nachdem ich ja
nur von windows auf windows gehe nehme ich halt eine windows only software die funktioniert synergy
funktioniert auch aber ist ein bisschen komplizierter einzurichten
also die musik auf ubuntu mach hinne
ja auf chat
um den chat zu erfreuen
ob das habe ich jetzt gemacht so als
genug jetzt habe ich mein netzwerk
verständigt weil brunner gefallen ist
das war noch einen iphone 6
die kamera ist ein iphone xs haare auf
dem arm liegt exakt zum glück hat man
nicht den anderen arm gesehen der ist
nämlich total verkratzt weil sich die
katze hat wieder ausgetobt hat
press f
ich lebe noch also muss ich dir recht
gehen kampf kevin ich finde von der
größe her das iphone 6 auch am
angenehmsten deswegen habe ich das auch
immer noch das neue das neue iphone se
ist ja so ungefähr die größe oder ist
glaube ich exakt die größe verwenden
wahrscheinlich dass alle zeug dafür das
alte iphone se ist mir ein bisschen klein
ich habe mir meiner mutter ein iphone se
gekauft ein altes und da haben wir jetzt
die schriftgröße ganz
festgestellt dass man etwas trifft und
die ist jetzt 70 vielleicht liegt auch
daran dass er das nicht mehr so gut mit
dem finger trifft aber das wäre mir
auch ein bisschen klein
das ist die ist wirklich boomer was das
angeht ich bin eher dummer weil ich bin
ja 2000 so am start gewesen
ich bin 1984 geboren das heißt ich war
2016 aber das war 2000 war das ewig sich
also du hattest ja welche die haben
wirklich geglaubt dass das jetzt dass das
dass die welt morgen nicht mehr
existiert so nach dem motto auch
gedacht also es wird morgen exakt so
sein wie vorher bloß wird kein
silvester mehr sein und es ist ja auch
nichts passiert es ist nichts
nennenswertes passiert im jahr 2000 die
haben wir die haben das gehypt fast das
ganze jahr lang über aber es ist nichts
passiert paar jahre später gab es dann
mega upload paar jahre später gab es dann
gerade dabei sind moment das ist die ja
wo ihr besser
mega upload ja da hast du da sagst du
was was cooles
oh what the fuck hat er meine tastatur
nicht geklappt ok da sagt er nämlich was
gut ist und zwar nicht wow what the fuck
ist hier los was den rapid share song
kann ich das hier aufmachen
war das ja grausam dann dann lieber der
der mega upload song rapid share song
kenn ich nicht mehr zumindest wollte ich
jetzt eigentlich mal sagen wir hier
genau er schreibt es ist passiert weil
in dem jahr davor wo man das war noch
alles gemacht hat ja die haben wirklich
alles alles scheu gemacht
was was geht und was man daran sieht
ist was was was man da wirklich schön
transit gut wie viel passiert wäre ist
an sich ungewiss ja aber man hat
wirklich alles mögliche gemacht und man
konnte doch wohl auch fett geld verdienen
zu dieser zeit man alles mögliche
gemacht dass im jahr 2000 nichts
großartiges passiert woran man wieder
sieht ist wenn die kacke so richtig am
dampfen ist und man damit rechnen muss
dass es morgen auf den sack gibt oder
richtig auf die fresse dann schafft die
menschheit irgendwie oder oder die
menschen an sich schaffen das irgendwie
dann in anbetracht zu der drohenden
gefahr die ja schon quasi sehr bald
eintritt schafft die was zu machen wenn
es so dinger sind sowie jahr in 20 30
jahren passiert dann was schlimmes juckt
keine sau das ist das sehe ich auch so
ein bisschen das problem wenn ich das
ich kann ein bisschen schwätzen werden
die die sache installiert wenn ich dann
sehe dass irgendwelche politischen
entscheidungen die jetzt eigentlich
getroffen werden müssten dann gesagt
wird ach ja wir machen einen plan der
2038 dann umgesetzt was ein schwachsinn
dass juk 2038 absolut nicht mehr nicht
nur keine sau das juckt noch liegt man
kann gar nicht beschreiben wie wenig das
2038 überhaupt noch jemand juckt das
übrigens ist auch eine sache ich kann
jetzt ja wenn das ist ein bisschen
eine sache die ich vermisse warum ich
auch wirklich absolut kein plan habe
wenig wählen soll ich habe das gefühl
niemand hat von zumindest von den
größeren parteien hat irgendwie eine
zukunftsvision die er sich traut auch
mal der welt mitzuteilen es ist ja
vollkommen okay wenn jetzt einer sagt ja
meine zukunftsvision ist keine flüge
mehr keine kreuzfahrten mehr das nicht das nicht dass meinetwegen das muss ich
sagen da kann ich immer noch so okay die zukunft vision gefällt mir nicht dass
wenig nicht aber wenigstens wenigstens hat man dann eine so aber aktuell
äußert sich da keiner zu und ich meine nicht so sachen mit nicht so nicht so
klein scheiß den sie immer erzählen so nach dem motto ja unsere städten müssen
elektroauto freundlicher werden sonst was alles schön und gut wenn ich mal
wirklich mal jemand der sich die man wirklich sagen okay so stellen wir uns
die welt meinetwegen 2000 30 2040 vor und das und das sind die ziele das und
das müssen wir jetzt machen und dann machen und daran dass wir dahin kommen
dann kann ich mir immer noch denjenigen raussuchen wo mir das am besten gefällt
oder was für am realistischsten halte aber was aktuell gemacht wird ist einfach
nur mal so pauschal die ist lustigerweise die
piraten habe ich früher sogar ein paar mal gewählt als als es die noch gehabt so
irgendwie ich weiß dass es die noch theoretisch gibt aber ja also eigentlich
ist da da ist nichts mehr da der hat sich hat sich aus aus piratet so da
werden dann so dinge also gibt es zwei aussagen die ich in letzter zeit diese
komplett einfach mal in den raum geschmissen wurden um wohl gut wetter bei
speziellen zielgruppen zu machen das erste war dass irgendeine politiker von
sich gegeben hat so nach dem motto
ärzte dürfen nur noch in krankenhäuser arbeiten wenn sie abtreibung vornehmen
wollen willst du das jetzt von oben erlassen oder was so komplett ohne
kontext einfach mal raus gehauen so und dann habe ich vor ein paar tagen gehört
hat irgendjemand gesagt ich glaube es war sogar auf hessen bezogen hat irgendjemand
gesagt ab jetzt sollen keine straßen mehr gebaut werden
das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn dass das ist ohne kontext drumherum ist es
komplett einfach kommt nur irgendwas ganz
wirklich
also
erst an
unserem
ATO
Julian
Erk clearly
Herr
der
hat
gesagt
wäre
er
zu sagen
fans gut das ist eine aussage da kann ich was mit anfangen aber einfach nur
so pauschale dinge das ist genauso wie breitband ziele wir haben noch nicht ein
einziges breitband ziel erreicht und anstatt dass man darauf eingeht wie das
mit breitband zielen nicht geklappt hat macht man einfach neue breitband ziele
das ist auch so eine geile taktik ach moment wie 50 mbit für jeden bis 2018
haben wir nicht geschafft naja gut da war gigabit bis 2025 oder was auch immer
das ist und ich fand es wirklich gut da gebe ich captain peng recht ich fand
wirklich gut wenn man nicht nur einfach so pauschale aussagen treffen würde
sondern vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen erklären würde in welchem kontext man
das meint und ganz wichtig was ist mein das ist das was ich mit zukunft vision
meine die irgendwie da mit mir keiner vermitteln kann
wie kommt man da hin weil es ist ja es ist ist ja unrealistisch wenn man sagt
zu
beispiel wir können super umweltfreundlich sein werden allerdings
ohne jegliche einschränkungen alles so machen wie bisher
es gibt keinen sinn also zumindest nicht so pauschal man könnte man könnte
vielleicht sagen okay dass wir müssen wir müssen das alles umweltfreundlicher
machen und in dem und den bereichen wollen wir in forschung investieren und
sonstige geschichten so dass man quasi
in zukunft kaum einschränkungen spürt was auch immer so ein bisschen mit
kontext drumherum aber gibt es nicht wenn du kannst du nicht ernsthaft den
leuten erzählen wollen wir können das super umweltfreundlich alles machen aber
aber aber im prinzip wir machen einfach alles wie bisher aber aber
umweltfreundlich das ergibt doch absolut keinen sinn
oh mist ich habe müsste pxe überspringen und und dann frage ich mich so ist das
so also was war zuerst da gibt es diese sinnlosen aussagen die wir jetzt hier
haben die wir jetzt hier haben die wir jetzt hier haben die wir jetzt hier haben
die wir jetzt hier haben die wir jetzt hier haben die wir jetzt hier haben
die wir jetzt hier haben auch sonst noch tweets zu attestieren und nur
sozusagen weil man denkt dass wir powerful gegenüber uns™
sagen weil man denkt ordentliche aussagen würden die leuten nicht
verstehen oder sind sie zu blöd ordentliche aussagen zu machen und was
oder oder was war zuerst da ich glaube es ist beides die meisten leute haben
gar kein bock bisschen komplexe sachverhalte sich im hirn zusammen zu
raffen und dementsprechend kriegt man nur noch praxis wirken
so
Das ist, das, deswegen habe ich halt auch den Eindruck, oh was heißt Eindruck, also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass es tatsächlich so ist, dass man sich nicht darauf verlassen kann, dass jemand was in seinem Interesse macht.
Hallo, bootet das jetzt oder bootet das jetzt nicht? Ubuntu, hast du gebootet oder nicht? Control, Alt, F2, ah, Ubuntu ist da, hä, was für ein Kram, äh, was habe ich für einen Benutzernamen genommen, Max, Max, hallo, ich darf nicht tippen, ich möchte, Ubuntu, ich möchte tippen, hallo, tippen, what the f, was, Rollen ist an, nee, Scroll-Log, nicht Rollen, Scroll-Log,
Scroll-Log, okay, äh, ah, MS habe ich genommen, aha, excellent, Chat, Chat weiß Bescheid, okay, wir haben eine IP 2, 1, 4, 3, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das Durchreichen von der Netzwerkkarte funktioniert, 1, 4, 3, als Root, ach, Moment, als Root geht ja nicht, äh, als, als, ähm, äh, Frage, welches gute Microsoft Office benutzt ihr bei euch in der Firma?
Ähm, wir haben lokal, was ist das, 2019 installiert und Office 365, aber wie gesagt, ich verwende kein Office, ich verwende für nix Office, Office suckt, haben wir noch schnell ein Update, so, hä, oh, excellent, so, naja gut, äh, so, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das, ob das Durchreichen der, äh, Netzwerkkarte ordentlich funktioniert, tja, wie gesagt, ich muss, ich lasse mich ja öfters mal so während was läuft zu, zu, zu, zu aktuellen Themen, aber, äh,
und, ähm, ich möchte das jetzt nochmal schnell abschließen, ähm, aus, aus, aus den genannten Gründen, dass ich keinen da irgendwie aktuell für, ähm, fähig halte, überhaupt irgendwie sowas wie eine Zukunftsvision zu haben, geschweige denn irgendwie einen sinnvollen Plan, wie man da hinkommt, unabhängig davon, ob ich das ähnlich sehe, ja, wie die oder nicht, aber wenigstens erstmal so eine Zukunftsvision haben, und deswegen bin ich mir mittlerweile ziemlich sicher, dass man sich absolut nicht drauf verlassen kann,
dass irgendjemand,
also jetzt politische Entscheidung
mäßig, irgendjemand was
macht
für mich,
dich, sonst wer, also, dass, dass
man nicht damit rechnen kann, dass man,
dass man im,
dass man so im eigenen Interesse vertreten wird,
ja, also, das hab ich,
das hab ich mir abgeschminkt, und leider ist es halt so,
dass die einzige
Konsequenz daraus
ist, so doof es sich jetzt
anhört, zu gucken,
dass man selbst
so unabhängig ist, wie es irgendwie geht.
Also sprich, dass man selbst
guckt, dass man seine Sachen, wie man
so schön sagt, im Trockenen hat,
dass man möglichst wenig auf seine Umwelt
angewiesen ist. Leider ist das so,
dass, es führt natürlich auch dazu,
dass, äh, deswegen die Leute
immer weniger Rücksicht aufeinander nehmen,
und sich immer beschissener verhalten,
und, äh,
ja, sich gegenseitig mehr abfangen,
und, äh, so,
weniger, wie nennt man das,
was so schön, Nixliebe ist jetzt ein doofes Wort,
äh, weniger sich für ihre Umwelt
interessieren, aber,
die meisten Leute können sich das halt schlicht und ergreifend
nicht mehr leisten. Und nachdem man nicht
damit rechnen muss, dass irgendeiner
dort im Interesse was macht,
wird es wahrscheinlich einfach nur noch immer schlimmer werden.
Ich mein, ich guck
jeden Monat drauf, wie viel Steuern
ich bezahle, so, und dann überleg ich mir
so davon, was, was, was
bekomm ich denn so mit,
was gemacht
wird, so wirklich, wo ich sag, okay, das ist,
das wird irgendwie in meinem Interesse verwendet.
Es ist weder Infrastrukturaufbau,
noch sind es irgendwie
Krankengesundheitssystem, noch sind es
irgendwie Kindergartenplätze. Ich hab zum Beispiel
von meinem Nachbarn mitgekriegt,
dass die Tochter jetzt nicht in den Kindergarten kann, obwohl die
anderen zwei Kinder da auch schon hingehen.
Ähm,
gerade Infrastruktur, wenn man mal auf
Internet und sonst was gucken, wird deutlich schlechter,
also, was heißt deutlich schlechter?
Es wird besser, aber es wird im Vergleich
zum, zum Standard drumherum,
der Abstand wird immer größer,
ähm, also, da gibt's
nicht so viele Sachen, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja,
dafür darf, darf, darf,
ich mein, ich hab kein Problem,
Steuern zu bezahlen, aber es hätte doch
irgendwie seinen Charme, wenn man sagen könnte, okay,
das wurde jetzt für was
verwendet, wo ich, wo ich
auch sag, ja, das ist wichtig.
Also, den Eindruck
hab ich jetzt einfach nicht. Ich will nicht
sagen, dass es für nichts ausgegeben
wird, was mir was bringt,
ha, aber,
so von dem, wo ich sage, hey,
ja, das ist was,
das wurde quasi von meinen Steuern gelb mitbezahlt,
und das find ich gut, kommt wirklich ziemlich,
äh, ziemlich wenig, ja.
Man sieht's ja auch schon, wenn man sich
Nahverkehr-Zeug anguckt,
ja, man kann sagen, ja, okay, die Bad ist privat,
Bahn, Bahn und Telekom und sowas, das ist alles
privat, ist es ja auch nicht so
wirklich hundertprozentig,
ähm, aber, ich bin
auch der Ansicht, gerade was Krankenhäuser
angeht, das ist nix, was großartig
Gewinn machen soll. Krankenhäuser
sollte für die Versorgung der,
der Einwohner oder der Bevölkerung
letztendlich sein, und nicht
dort irgendwie großartig Geld machen.
Wenn man schon sieht,
dass beispielsweise Leute Hüft-,
Knie- und sonst was OPs bekommen,
weil es Geld bringt,
ähm,
sobald es medizinisch irgendwie vertretbar ist,
also sprich, man hätte jetzt die Auswahl,
okay, man könnte noch ein paar alternative
Sachen probieren, aber das zieht sich
zwei, drei Jahre hin, kostet Geld,
oder, ähm, man macht jetzt einfach mal
dicke Hüft-OP und verdient,
ein paar tausend, was weiß ich, wie viel man da dran verdient,
dann macht man lieber Hüft-OP.
Ob das jetzt so die, die beste Behandlung ist,
im Sinne desjenigen,
dem sein Knie kaputt ist, sei mal dahingestellt,
ja?
So, und woran man das auch gesehen hat,
dass eigentlich nur gelabert
wird und nichts gemacht wird.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran?
Ähm,
Anfang des Jahres,
wo so Corona richtig losging,
wo, wo sie gesagt haben, oh scheiß,
wir haben zu wenig Krankenpfleger, zu wenig Altenpfleger,
zu wenig Gesundheitssystem und sonst was,
wo die dann alle gesagt haben,
oder, oder auch, ähm, Supermarktmitarbeiter
und sowas, was haben die
alle rumgeschleimt, ey?
So nach dem Motto,
oh, ihr seid unsere, unsere
Helden im Alltag, und dann sind sie dann
ans Fenster gegangen und haben die Leute klatschen lassen
für die, für die Gesundheitspflege und sowas.
Alles schön und gut,
ich sag nicht, dass das schlecht ist, aber
davon können die sich alle
nichts kaufen. Und sie haben
natürlich wild bekundet, so nach dem Motto,
oh, jetzt gibt's dicken Bonus, es gibt dicke,
dicke Erhöhung und Geld
und nix, nix!
Und was ist die logische Konsequenz
für jemand daraus, der sowas erfährt?
Der kommt zu dem gleichen Schluss,
was ich eben auch schon gesagt hab, okay,
du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass jemand was in meinem Interesse
macht, das heißt,
das nächste Mal sind die
Leute deutlich weniger rück-,
wie nennt man das, weil man weniger,
weniger, äh, rücksichtsvoll ist, also,
weniger, weniger rücksichtsvoll und
sagen dann, okay, ähm,
tja,
da komm ich jetzt einfach mal nicht auf die Arbeit, oder
was weiß ich, da melde ich mich krank, oder dann
vielleicht sollten wir doch mal streiken, dann sind halt zu wenig
Altenpfleger oder sonst was, da sterben halt ein paar
Leute, das wird den Leuten nach und nach
immer mehr egal.
Weil sie halt merken, okay,
es setzt sich keiner für mich ein.
Ja, aber,
das ist die logische, eigentlich die logische
Entwicklung. Und das müssen wir eigentlich mal
durchbrechen, aber es geht
eigentlich, es geht eher in die komplett,
äh, andere Richtung.
Und dazu kommt's, dass sowas natürlich
auch dazu führt,
dass, äh,
Extreme,
also Leute extremer werden
in ihren Ansichten, ne,
wenn du, wenn du permanent dir verarscht
vorkommst, natürlich wirst du irgendwann extremer in deinen
Ansichten, ähm,
und das ist letztendlich
der aktuellen
Mainstream-Politik zu verdanken, wie das,
wie das gerade läuft oder nicht läuft.
Und das, wie gesagt, ich find's auch nicht
gut. Für mich hab ich das schon
seit ein paar Jahren festgestellt, das Einzige, was man
machen kann, ist gucken,
dass man selbst
genug für sich am Start
hat, dass man genug Geld hat, dass man ein Haus
hat, das muss ja kein Haus sein in dem
Sinn, ja, aber dass man einfach seine Sachen im Trockenen hat
und nicht darauf angewiesen
ist, dass irgendjemand anderes was für dich
macht, weil da hast du ja echt gelitten mittlerweile.
Es ist ja auch schon der Witz, wenn man sich das anguckt,
wie das bei der Bahn läuft,
ähm,
die Bahn ist auch
so ein Ding.
Das sollte eigentlich
dafür da sein, um die Leute
mit, nennen wir's mal, Mobilität
zu versorgen, also sprich, dass man
auch ohne Auto oder, oder,
selbst wenn man ein Auto hat, dass man eben von A nach
B mit dem Zug fahren kann,
zuverlässig, und, äh,
dass da nicht auch noch Fahrgäste gegeneinander ausgespielt
werden. Ich mein, wenn man sich das anguckt,
dass, ähm, ICEs
teilweise jetzt, gab's
beim letzten, äh, Computer,
Chaos Computer Kongress, gab's da einen schönen Vortrag
dazu, dass, dass jetzt ICEs
teilweise anhalten
und nicht mehr weiterfahren und wieder umdrehen,
also die, die lassen,
keine Ahnung, die letzten zwei, drei Halte ausfallen
und drehen wieder um,
weil das dann in der Pünktlichkeitsstatistik
besser aussieht, das ist der komplette
Witz. Was sollen denn die Leute sagen, die da drin,
die da drin? Meint ihr, so Leute fahren weiter
mit der Bahn? So Leute fahren auch nicht
im Leben, die sagen, okay, ich hab jetzt die
Auswahl zwischen so einem Scheiß oder meinem Auto,
mit dem Auto ist es vielleicht umweltschädlicher
und ist es vielleicht, äh, unangenehmer
so lange Strecken zu fahren, aber
ich komm wenigstens an, also,
also meine persönliche Meinung ist,
Nahverkehr, gerade Nahverkehr, aber
sagen wir mal, Fernverkehr ist, äh,
natürlich auch, aber gerade
Nahverkehr müsste eigentlich,
dass man ernsthaft darüber nachdenken
kann, ähm,
dass man ernsthaft darüber nachdenken kann,
beispielsweise Verbrennerautos in Städten
zu verbieten, so Sachen spuken
ja, spuken ja gerade rum.
Das ist eine Sache, die finde ich
jetzt als wenig Autofahrer
an sich gar nicht so schlecht.
Wenn man sagt, okay, dann ist bessere Luft
in der Stadt und sonst was, aber das hängt ja an,
das hängt ja an zwei ganz wichtigen Faktoren.
Erstens muss man
sich fragen, okay, klar,
dass die Luft in der Stadt wird
besser, aber so wirklich umweltfreundlich
ist das nicht, solange
das Zeug,
mit dem du deine Batterien lädst, oder besser gesagt,
deine Akkus lädst, eben nicht,
ähm,
umweltschonend
hergestellt wird. Das muss
die komplette Sache mit, ähm,
Akku herstellen,
Autos herstellen,
und sagen wir über den
Zeitraum, wie so ein Auto lebt,
laden, dass das
günstiger ist,
oder umweltfreundlicher ist,
als eben ein Verbrennerauto.
Erst dann
hat das ja Sinn. Wozu, wozu
soll ich sonst Verbrennerautos verbieten, wenn das auch nicht umweltfreundlich ist?
Das ergibt doch eigentlich auch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Also ich mein, Elektroauto ist ja nicht per se
umweltfreundlich, nur weil es ein Elektroauto
ist. Der Strom muss ja irgendwo herkommen,
der Akku muss irgendwo gebaut werden,
das Auto muss auch irgendwo hergestellt werden.
Das heißt, du musst da auch die Voraussetzung für schaffen,
dass das funktioniert.
Das ist der erste Punkt, wo ich sag, okay,
aus aktuellem Gesichtspunkt
vielleicht wenig sinnvoll,
ähm, quasi,
dass Leuten mit Verbrennerautos
das Leben schwerer zu machen, in der
Stadt, um auf die Arbeit zu kommen. Und der zweite
Punkt, der meiner Meinung nach
komplett außer Acht gelassen wird,
ähm,
man muss das
nicht durch verbieten machen,
sondern man muss den Leuten zeigen,
dass es Alternativen gibt.
Hätte man die Möglichkeit,
Frankfurt und Umgebung,
sagen wir mal, im 10-15-Minuten-Takt
sicher
zu fahren und an seinen Arbeitsplatz
zu kommen, da würden viele Leute
freiwillig, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher,
Leute freiwillig das Auto stehen lassen,
weil die wenigsten fahren gerne mit dem Auto
nach Frankfurt morgens.
Mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt ist
Kacke. Sackt einfach nur.
So, und, ähm,
wenn es halt ordentliche Alternativen gäbe,
auf die man sich verlassen kann,
so,
dann würden ganz viele Leute sagen, ja gut, dann lassen wir das Auto
daheim. Aber solange
das nicht der Fall ist,
was sollen die Leute denn machen?
Sollen die auf einmal nicht mehr arbeiten gehen, oder was?
Naja, äh,
es gibt, es gibt da so viele Dinge, wo ich
mich frage, irgendwie, irgendwie hat keiner
so wirklich eine Zukunft, irgendeine
Zukunftsvision, wo ich sage, okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Aber aktuell ist es halt so,
ich mein, ich fahr mit dem Zug, ich
muss jetzt übrigens mal gucken, ob der die, äh,
die Netzwerke hat durchgereist,
ich fahr ja mit dem Zug, und ich hab wirklich eine einfache
Strecke. Ich kann direkt quasi
von mir losfahren, nach Frankfurt
an den Hauptbahnhof. Und sogar
ich bin täglich, fast täglich,
am Kotzen über irgendwas.
Und meine Strecke ist wirklich easy
as fuck. Wie ist das dann erst,
wenn du eins oder gar zwei, dreimal umsteigen musst?
Kannste komplett knicken. So, wie, wie
reicht mir denn jetzt die Hardware durch?
War mal das für die Fernverkehr AG,
okay. Ja, aber das ist halt kacke,
ne? Weil's letztendlich dazu
führt, dass die Leute kein Vertrauen in
dieses Fortbewegungsmittel irgendwie haben können.
Wenn du, wenn du
Zug fährst und nicht weißt, ob du ankommst,
ist halt, schafft nicht
unbedingt Vertrauen in die Bahn, ne?
So, wie leitet man denn jetzt hier
Netzwerkgeräte durch? Oder wie leitet man denn jetzt
hier überhaupt Sachen durch?
Add? PCI-Device.
Was muss ich machen?
Hat er jetzt irgendwelche Schmerzen?
C-Documentation. Okay, welche
welche Documentation?
Intel? Jaja,
VTD haben wir schon eingeschaltet.
Okay, also, was muss man machen?
Crap? Was? ETC?
Crap?
Ey, was? Wohin? ETC
defaults. Aha. ETC
defaults. Crap.
Und dann hier? Okay, quiet
machen wir schon mal raus. Das?
Okay,
das war's? Update Crap.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d
d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d
Wie machst du das
eigentlich, dass du in deiner Bash-Historie sogar Steuerung R
Oh, da sind wir noch nicht fertig.
Oh Leute, es ist 22 Uhr. Ich muss gleich ins Bett.
Machen wir KS.
Jetzt aber hier. Jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's aber eng.
Aber das mit dem Netzwerkgerät durchreichen, will ich
noch ausprobieren. Hallo, haben
heute noch mal ja natürlich da hast recht mister kdh klar das verkehrsaufkommen ist massig gestiegen
und den letzten jahren hat man nicht richtig ausgebaut man hat sogar eher abgebaut man hat
total viel abgebaut weil es zu viel gekostet hat viele strecken sind stillgelegt worden für viele
gleise und viele weichen und gedöns wurden stillgelegt weil du das weil das zu viel gekostet
hat und quasi das verkehrsaufkommen ist gestiegen und man hat die sache noch abgebaut man muss sich
nicht wundern dass es dadurch schlechter wird ja also das sind halt gerade die dinger wo ich
bedenke okay wenn du willst dass die leute wirklich nicht mit dem arbeit mit dem volker
sein mit dem mit dem arbeit auf das auto fahren was nicht sind ergibt mit dem auto auf die arbeit
fahren dann muss das halt funktionieren du musst halt zuverlässig ankommen was er aktuell nicht so
ist und deswegen wirst du das auch nicht die leute abgewöhnen können
und das was man jetzt macht ist genau die falschen treffen wenn man damit jetzt anfängt und sagt hier
musste damit noch mehr steuern für das auto bezahlen weil auch kein elektroauto hast jetzt
musste ich musste hier jenes machen du kannst doch guck mal also was ich halt nicht verstehe
ist was ergibt es für einen sinn wenn man die leute die ich schon quasi am limit sind noch
weiter belastet und angeblich mit vorwänden die wo die voraussetzungen
noch gar nicht geschaffen sind du kannst nicht zu dem 08 15 mensch der auf die arbeit fährt und
der sonst dreimal mit der bahn umsteigen müsste oder irgendwie die uns auf der strecke ist zu
sagen nein du darfst jetzt nicht mehr mit dem auto fahren oder das für den so teuer machen dass er
quasi mehr fürs auto bezahlt als auf der arbeit verdient um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sein
da gibt doch keinen sinn du kannst doch das ist der zweite oder das ist der dritte schritt vor
dem ersten schritt ich sehe es auch so also ich fände es super wenn in frankfurt weniger autos
wären klar und und wenn das wenn wir noch elektroautos hätten dass die luft auch da bin
ich sofort dafür aber ohne die voraussetzung dafür kann das doch gar nicht funktionieren
und sie diese dieser zusammenhang erschließt sich mir nicht warum man warum man immer so dinge
entscheidet und sie dann hinstellt so nach dem oder das muss jetzt gemacht werden ohne dass die
voraussetzungen dafür da sind das ist wie unsere breitband ziele die wir noch nie erreicht haben
aber angeblich schaffen wir jetzt ein gigabit bis frag mich nicht
2025 wie soll das denn gehen das wächst doch nicht auf bäumen start da hat ja jetzt
durchgereicht excellent doch die art wird es durchgereicht mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert
hat ja ich weiß ich muss ich muss px noch abbrechen ich muss die buchreihen folge ändern und jetzt
waiting for link ab ach vielleicht leute vielleicht
ist net null net null ist schon die das wird schon die zweite grafik die zweite
das wird schon die netzwerkkarte sein oder ja das ist schon die zweite
netzwerkkarte kommen wir sehen wir sehen schon am pxe boot dass er das erkannt
hat so jetzt müsste er müsste starten der hat die netzwerkkarte erkannt
ziemlich sicher sonst würde jetzt nicht sonst hätte er jetzt nicht pxe boot von
zwei netzwerkkarten gemacht das hat funktioniert du dürftest jetzt
einmal starten ubuntu na booten please wir machen jetzt mal aus und und
ändern mal die boot reihenfolge auf disk und den rest mal aus weil wir brauchen
nur noch disk wo ist jetzt das problem warum bootet er jetzt nicht ok machen wir mal aus
stop m so und jetzt sollte er eigentlich disk booten moin kyokun ah jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
wird gebootet ja booting vom hard disk post champ kann das sein dass der
probleme hat mit durchgereichten pc geräten weil er bootet nicht
der kyokun sagt habe letztens habe letzten donnerstag mit praktikum
angefangen habe skype for business 2000 oh pants champ noch nicht mal teams das ist
das ist schlecht pants champ skype for business 239 der größte scheiß überhaupt ok der bootet nicht
nicht mehr wenn ich die wenn ich die wenn ich das durchgereicht habe wir
gucken mal ob es an der wir gucken ob es daran liegt habe ich schon ich habe
schon habe schon das zeug aktiviert im club buching vom hard disk das liegt da
dran jetzt buchte da ja ja im bios ist alles an
der buchte nicht mehr durchgereicht wo ist das jetzt gelb der buchte nicht
mehr durchgereichte netzwerkkarte dass ich bin mir aber ziemlich sicher das
liegt nicht an proxmox das liegt an diesem cardboard dass es nicht richtig
funktioniert ziemlich sicher dass das nicht mag
heute ist es spät wo es jetzt ich muss jetzt gleich oft ich hoffe euch hat es
gefallen werde also ich muss sagen jetzt mal sagen das neue proxmox gefällt mir
viel besser als das als die letzte version und der hauptsächliche punkt ist
man kann jetzt einen container laufen lassen indem man direkt docker laufen
lassen kann und man braucht keine unsinnige vm mehr wenn man gar keine
fans verwenden will das finde ich sinnvoll
das ui ist gewöhnungslos
bedürftig aber ich denke man gewöhnt sich dran
das war jetzt bescheuert der satz wenn es gewöhnungsbedürftig ist aber ich denke
man gewöhnt sich dran so super intuitiv finde ich nicht aber man man gewöhnt
sich dran ziemlich sicher ob ich es einsetzen werde weiß ich nicht eher
nicht wie gesagt ich bin mit meinem aktuellen setup aus ubuntu server und
part paar container über docker compose bin ich ehrlich gesagt recht zufrieden
Guck mal, ob er sich ausschaltet, ob er das hinbekommt, fährt er sich runter, Resident Sleeper Champ, was würde dir noch bei Proxmox gefehlt, also nachdem ich mir gerade gestern diese Synology Geschichte angeguckt habe, also was ich da schick fand, war das Management von Docker Containern, das war ganz praktisch,
auf der anderen Seite ein Ubuntu mit einem Docker-Truff oder so und dann ein eigenes Komponent, das ist auch okay, da müssen wir jetzt mal Gedanken machen, also direkte Docker-Integration wäre auf jeden Fall nützlich, aber so wie es jetzt ist, ist okay, es sind Debian drunter, man kann mehr oder weniger alles machen, Fileserver hätte man nochmal probieren können, wie es ist mit einer externen Platte, wenn man das durchreicht, aber alles in allem ist es eigentlich ganz nice,
aber wie gesagt, ich glaube trotzdem, dass ich es nicht verwenden werde, weil ich bin mit meinem aktuellen Setup einfach Ubuntu...
...Ubuntu Server 5.6.7 Container drauf, fertig, relativ zufrieden und nachdem ich eh keine VMs laufen habe, ist das eigentlich Overkill, sowas wie Proxmox zu verwenden.
Hast du PCIe Pass-Through jetzt hinbekommen? Ja, aber die VM hat nicht mal gestartet, aber das schiebe ich mal auf das Board, dass das Board nicht für sowas gedacht ist, oder aber ich müsste mal probieren, wenn ich, wenn ich, wobei ich kann den anderen PCIe Express Slot nicht nehmen, da ist die Karte...
...zu groß, dass der mehr durchgereicht hat, als nötig war und deswegen rumgespackt hat, oder ich irgendwelche Optionen noch setzen müsste, das müsste man mal ausprobieren, aber ansonsten ist es ganz praktisch, das, ich finde die Oberfläche könnte noch ein bisschen strukturierter sein, es ist jetzt für mich nicht intuitiv gewesen, was zu finden, aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so das große Problem, wenn man das ein paar Tage verwendet, kommt man da ziemlich gut rein, denke ich.
Ja, eine Sache, die ich noch richtig cool finden würde, ist, wenn man...
...keine ISOs downloaden müsste, sondern wenn das das für einen machen könnte, so eine reine Convenience-Geschichte, also sprich, man wählt aus, okay, ich möchte ein Ubuntu 20.04 installieren und er guckt nach, aha, ich habe noch kein ISO dafür oder noch kein Image dafür und dann lade ich dir das schnell runter, das wäre auch kein allzu großer Akt, dort irgendwie einen Pfeil zu hinterlegen, was, weißt du, die müssten im Prinzip einfach nur einen Pfeil mitliefern,
mit Server-Distributionsname, Download-Url, mit ein paar Alternativen und im Hintergrund dann irgendwie ein WayGuard machen oder sowas, das stelle ich mir jetzt nicht so kompliziert vor, sowas einzubauen.
Kann man mal Proxmox, Lox und so auslagern?
Ähm, das weiß ich nicht, das habe ich nicht ausprobiert jetzt.
Aber nachdem die da ziemlich viel Cluster-Gedöns stehen hatten, würde ich mal drauf tippen, dass man...
...aber ob es mit Lox geht, keine Ahnung, aber ich würde mal drauf tippen, dass man da schon was machen kann.
Da habe ich halt von der SSD laufen, aber klar, wenn man es vom USB-Stick laufen will, das ist ja gerade auch das Schöne, was ESX macht und, was hatte ich letztens, ähm, ja auch hier, gestern, dieses Synology-Ding, da ist ziemlich viel, ziemlich viel Read-Only auf dem USB-Stick, weil USB-Sticks gehen halt wirklich gerne mal kaputt.
Das habe ich unten an dem Raspberry Pi, wo mein Unify-Controller läuft und wo mein Web-Interface...
...für die, für die ganzen Kameras läuft, habe ich das auch so, das nimmt ab und zu mal von den Kameras ein bisschen was auf und das schreibe ich auch alles auf dem USB-Stick, weil ich Schiss habe, dass die SD-Karte kaputt geht.
Mir ist lieber, der USB-Stick geht kaputt, dann sind ein paar Videoaufnahmen weg, als dass das ganze Ding abkackt.
Die Musik, weil die Playlist gefällt mir, die ist schön entspannt.
Wie ist das hier so?
Aha, exzellent.
Gucken wir mal, speichern.
Ordentlich Musik.
Wir machen mal einen Ordner.
Wir machen hier mal einen Ordner, warte mal.
New Folder.
Musik.
Wo ist der Ordner hin?
Das ist übrigens auch eine Sache, die ich an Chrome nicht mag.
Dass man das nicht so ohne weiteres gescheit verschieben kann.
So, zack.
Musik.
Ähm.
Der Desktop, der ist exquisite.
Bester Desktop.
Oder Chat.
Meint ihr wirklich, irgendjemand hat noch einen aufgeräumteren Desktop, als ich?
Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen.
Ja.
ESX funktioniert weiter.
ESX komplett im RAM.
Also das ist komplett mehr oder weniger auf Read-Only geschaltet dann alles.
Okay Chat, ich werde jetzt ins Bett.
Brauchen wir noch Outromusik?
Wie sieht's heute aus?
Muss Outromusik sein?
Outromusik.
Also, wir sehen uns die Tage, vielleicht sogar morgen schon.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.